the governor
of arizona says that he is not going to
accept the results of the election
yes he won't accept election results
until all lawsuits
are settled i want to make sure i get
that correct because precise language is
important right now
and if that means that the lawsuits are
ongoing and they don't certify
by i guess the soft deadline federally
which is like december 8th then arizona
has no electoral votes
we've already seen two of the canvas
board members republicans
they initially rejected certification of
wayne county in michigan calling the
whole
state in question then they agreed to
certify if they got nodded then they
rescinded saying that they were being
threatened
and they were lied to now the democrats
are saying you can't rescind your vote
but regardless this puts two states in
question if the governor of arizona
won't accept the election results
i don't know what's going to happen but
questions uh
arise in which case potentially
they don't certify that means trump
would just need one state like
pennsylvania
and then it goes to house delegations
and trump gets reelected
i know the left like to say it's silly
it's impossible never happen but
stranger things have happened donald
trump won in 2016 for instance
and he might win again and i think it's
ridiculous these people are
underestimating him so
you know we're we're gonna start with
this because this is this is like the
big story you know uh giuliani came out
today in this press conference cindy
powell they talked a bit about this
and the media keeps lying saying there's
no evidence we now have
legitimate hard data and sworn
statements
of widespread voter irregularity period
they can't say it anymore the media
can't lie we've got this it's from matt
brennan the voter integrity
integrity fund where they've actually
found widespread irregularities
in returned ballots it's a fact so i'm
not saying fraud because we don't know
how this happened
but it seems like republicans when they
send their ballots back into the mail
they just kind of disappeared so
we'll talk about all this stuff we have
a very special guest today well
it's always a special guest we're joined
by george alexapolis
are you going to do the plant generally
no oh yeah i should switch to you
my my name is magnetic plants magnetic
plant
that is george alexapolis over there
hold on this is george
this is george hi guys it's really good
to meet you guys
it's it's really hard to pick up a pen
and draw but i try my best you guys
so for those yes this is uh this is the
dude who drew these terrifying
uh images like joe biden eating a young
a young girl
hey look at that behind
you have a crazy story about how they
tried to destroy your life because you
supported trump which i thought was
that's a hell of a way to jump in yeah
well we'll
we'll start with we'll talk about the
breaking news but i think that's why
yeah so long story short oh man how you
trying to destroy your life
yeah uh so i've been on i've been
drawing web comics for a very long time
online uh website my own personal
website i've
posted on reddit twitter whatever
friends posting on
their websites uh occasionally like i
would have something go viral like uh i
had a really famous
dark souls comic where uh i don't know
if you play games at all yeah of course
it was called action games versus dark
souls and some
two parents are like feeding their
little kid oh the kid doesn't want to
eat
what should we spoon feed him and the
kids like oh i demand food anyway so
they're spoonie feeding their kid that's
most
action games who cares yeah and then
dark souls is like a knight
who walks up to a kid and says oh you
want to eat and the kid's like yeah
and the knight puts a helmet and a huge
broadsword in his hands and says well
come get it
yeah and the joke was that dark souls is
hard
but i'm sorry oh no no no just just a
quick introduction to
you know who you are but i want to save
the bigger story about
how they tried to destroy you because
they save it yeah yeah we'll
we'll start with this election stuff
just like people are coming in but then
but then we'll we'll we'll jump in
because it's
gotcha i was gonna say like we'll get to
it but long story short
they loved your comics then someone
found you followed ben shapiro and that
was it and it was like among others i'm
sure
right yeah so they they scrutinized my
twitter
at the time i had like 200 people yeah
so from reddit it's crazy i was the
number one
highest voted comic on reddit of all
time
this was in december 2018 they moved on
to twitter to find out who i was like
who's this guy that we just
elevated to be our quote king yeah
whatever and the joke
i'll tell you about the joke later i
guess but yeah we'll get in we're gonna
do it
so it's crazy but uh ian's sitting here
hi everyone thank you tim
and lydia is sitting here i'm sitting
here in the corner and we have a new a
new camera for our new uh
co-host on the show it is it is magnetic
levitating spinning plant
magnetic levitating spinning plant
magnetic levitating spinning split
spinning plant thank you for joining the
show
the new host the new co-host yeah we
just just when we get an awkward silence
we'll just
show that it'll be like elevate our
music i wonder though because
we got this thing i'm like does the
constant spinning affect the plant and
the magnetism because
this thing's been spinning non-stop for
several days
or probably longer than that and i
wonder if like you know it makes the
plant
unhappy i guess we'll see i had the same
feelings alex jones said it liked it
and i tend to believe alex jones yeah
anyway smash the like button subscribe
uh we do the show monday live at 8pm but
let's talk about this very very serious
development
yeah i gotta be honest so first of all
here's the story from a z family
governor ducey says he won't accept
election results until all lawsuits are
settled
they say uh during a press conference
was the first time we heard from
governor doug ducey since the election
several reporters asked him about the
debunked conspiracy theories in arizona
like sharpiegate
and if he accepts the election results
in arizona ducey made it pretty clear he
will not accept the presidential race
election results
until after all of the court filings are
resolved and until
every vote is counted on the one hand
the governor said we can trust our
elections here in arizona
but minutes later he said there are
questions and those questions should be
answered
these are legal claims that are being
challenged in court once those are
adjudicated and the process plays out i
will accept the results of the election
ducey would not acknowledge
president-elect joe biden as the winner
in arizona
but rather is holding out after several
lawsuits were filed by the trump
campaign and arizona gop
some which have already been dropped
those challenges will play out in court
and then i will respect the results of
the election but at the same time the
governor spoke
party chairs were inside the maricopa
county election center certifying the
accuracy of the election equipment
which matched up 100 percent for the
third audit
but arizona republican party chair kelly
ward came outside
to hold her own press conference calling
for a full hand audit of the election
who has access to the usb or the drives
that are used in the machines
who programmed the machines all of these
are very important as to what's going on
in the electoral process we need to know
these answers ward said
maricopa county democratic chair stephen
slagaki
said ward is putting on a show and is
frustrated anybody is still trying to
prove
any issues the deduction process he said
here's a quote i'm assuming it's from
him
here i am at the elections department
right now testing the machines testing
the equipment they matched up exactly
100 percent
and then literally kelly ward goes from
this room and then goes outside and
trashes the process
that we just certified as being accurate
we have
verified the vote we have verified the
machines there was no fraud here no
discrepancies i'm gonna stop right
there and just say in georgia there's
there's several things that kind of
were crazy three counties where they
uncovered
votes that were not tabulated more
importantly several sworn affidavits
from both republican and democrat alike
where they said some of these ballots
were
pristine no creases and it looked like
the vote for joe biden was like
machine printed like a perfect just
stamp right into the
you know dot for joe biden so it's weird
when the democrat when the republicans
are saying we want a hand audit
of these votes because you would see
then if you're looking through the votes
you're like that's
printed on a printer you would notice
right away so for them to be like no no
don't worry the machines say they're
good we're done to me
it's kind of strange can't they do tests
to find out if it was for instance ink
from a printer or
toner from a laser printer let's say
you'd have to do a hand audit
yeah i guess but not like the democrats
are resisting this every step of the way
yeah of course you'd think they'd be
like okay fine if we do this will you
accept the results
but instead they're like no we don't
have to investigate so this was really
interesting to me this is actually a
question that i asked on twitter
because rem you remember that gop guy
who won
they did a recount or something they
come up with a thousand extra
why wouldn't democrats then want
recounts of all of this that's
why because the race flipped for the
republicans so
yeah did you do you hear about what
happened with this guy in michigan he
was of today no this was like last week
or whatever this guy's a republican
and they announced he lost or whatever
the vote came in and he said i wasn't
going to call for a recount or anything
and i just accepted the results
and then he got a phone call saying oops
there was a glitch
you actually won and the republican
actually ended up winning
and so this led to more scrutiny and
then we saw a republican
noticed that six thousand of trump's
votes were registered for biden
and then said it's a computer collection
they said no no it's human air it's
human error
so we have we have all of this uh
widespread voter
irregularity stuff going on and uh it's
it's definitive at this point
the media is going to say no evidence of
widespread voter fraud that's a very
very specific thing and hard to prove
widespread and fraud proving fraud
is hard we can prove that people's votes
aren't being counted
that they're finding a bunch of you know
missing ballots and that it's widespread
i think we've done that at this point i
would think that the americans would
want
to verify the american election at this
point
regardless of political you saying that
democrats aren't americans i'm wondering
if they have america's best interests in
mind if they want to
you know steamroll an election that's a
great question
well there was a meme going around they
were saying like hey guys trump is
trying to steal the election
quick we have to do hand recounts yeah
frame it as we've got to stop trump
right and i think if
if people were led to believe that
that's the only way to verify that trump
lost
they'd go for it we should i think we
should that is the only way for them to
verify trump lost
and i wonder why then they're saying no
to it just accept the results as they
are
because they believe they already won so
let's run the clock
here's here's the thing trump is
potentially going to win now you have
arizona so i don't know to what extent
the governor can like block the
electoral certification i have no idea
maybe he can't because the state
legislators that decide ultimately where
the electors go
but this does throw az into some kind of
question
may not actually be that impactful but
we also have
uh michigan where these two you know
these two county uh canvasser or these
two board canvassers
said we rescind our votes we don't want
to certify so
if trump does get close to winning
through a contingent election
right now is the only opportunity for
democrats to prove trump lost by getting
a full hand recount in all of these
swing states
and they're resisting it so
if i was on their side and i thought
trump was
satan i suppose i would do the same
thing i mean they are
sure that he is the next hitler right
they
have to stop him by any means necessary
and this is probably the most humane way
they can do it and we are sure that joe
biden is some kind of lurking
monster in the shadows who eats children
i think he's being taken advantage of
my comments my comment yeah i think my
comics are one thing but me as a person
i just think he
he had ambitions since he was younger
and his party is pushing him
and he probably uh he's kind of it's
like a car that's
i don't mean to sound cruel it's kind of
he's just kind of rolling down the hill
with the momentum but if he's a car in
neutral
i hate to say it that way but it's true
i i feel like if you just
let him say what he was going to say
without coaching without you know
whatever uppers he was on during the
debates for instance
i don't feel like he would nearly he
wouldn't have nearly as much momentum as
if people were kind of propping him
up and pushing him shrewin and nana
shaba to pressure
yes that's the famous quote yes that and
the vatican the magic words he seemed
surprised when he won the um
primary you got a little yeah
while he was in the uh i like that uh
that my favorite comic from you probably
is i have it hanging my office it's the
one where uh joe biden said 200 million
people are going to die
yeah the electricity yeah so but joe
biden literally said
it is estimated by the time i finish
this talk 200 million people will die
poor guy and then the comic you made is
and then it shows his like eyes glowing
and he's like and that time is now and
then he fires the
lightning bolts and the crowd is getting
like it's the best
yeah oh my gosh it's my favorite you
know it's
you have to wonder about uh joe biden's
like
accidental statements when he says like
we made the largest vote
most inclusive voter fraud organization
in history my goodness
and then but then when he also so if
people think that he's being
if people think that he really meant it
and it was like a freudian slip or
whatever or like
he's losing his filter yeah okay so
people think that right
there are people who think he
accidentally admitted it because in his
old age right
does that mean when he said by the time
i finish his talk 200 million people
will die
he really met it he slipped he slipped
up yeah like joe biden is planning on
foreign about the great reset
yes yeah right he was foreshadowing it
they're like all these people are gonna
die in the pandemic and then he just
said it and they're like oh
said it you know you know what it really
is i'm sure uh
there's like this grand global
conspiracy and they're telling joe biden
all of their plans and using him as
they're like you know
he won't remember just telling no no no
he says it he just blurts it out
and then behind the scenes they're all
laughing like you know george soros and
hillary clinton they're like high-fiving
and they're like you just said it and
people just let them say it they're all
laughing
he just admitted to voter fraud and
nobody cares yeah
that's that's how sure of themselves
there and and uh what's betsy doing
oh come on that is so funny
it's kind of like a cause trouble it's
like the comic that george drew where
they're where george
uh sorry where joe is eating that little
girl and everyone is just
cheering like never really has no
clothes and they're just cheering away
like what's going on so so this uh
this picture that's behind it's behind
george right now i don't think we can
see it yeah i don't think we can see it
uh it's a woman is handing a little girl
to joe biden while everyone's cheering
and then joe biden's mouth opens up like
a giant monster about to eat the little
girl who's freaking out but there's
everyone giving thumbs up and cheering
yeah
and then after he eats it he looks at
the crowd and he's like he's a thumbs up
it actually is a very very powerful
political statement because when
when joe biden said that you know it's
it he believes that
uh what do you say battlecat cares a
human right they cheer they're like
yeah when he says trinidad shabbat
pressure they cheer and i'm like
what are they cheering for it's like
those uh lies what is this
applause sign going on yes we don't know
what he's saying just a plot
but i don't even the scary thing is
there's no applause sign they're just
mindless npcs going yay
joe biden's like a freaking blah blah
and they're like yes that's what i
wanted this whole time they're like
pounding on the table
donald trump comes out and he's like i'm
going to make more jabs lower
unemployment secure reporters
hitler joe biden turn it on a shop at a
pressure that's exactly what i was
expecting wanting to hear that's that's
that's what i'll vote for that it's kind
of like a weird
gladiator match where they just want to
cheer for their champion
to beat the other guy that's all it is
it's political gladiators
unfortunately they're like 70 years old
i think our leaders should be chosen by
blood sports is what i'm trying to say
so maybe like a hereditary uh
patriarchal
uh uh trial uh what what is it called um
patriarchal hereditary combat trial by
combat
no not trial choose like no like you
know
it was really funny that black panther
was considered this very progressive you
know
social justice movie but it's literally
about a king who's chosen based on
patriarchal heredity who has to fight
another man and women aren't allowed to
even try
interesting it's an interesting if we
want to go into the subconscious of what
they're really trying to say with these
stories if that's even possible with
corporate storytelling
uh it's it's a weird uh to unpack that
is
what are they trying to save
subconsciously what do they even not
know
they don't know what they're even saying
maybe they're not saying anything
you know it's like the funny thing about
black panther was that the movie was
basically
what did uh sargon i think sargon said
this it was adolf hitler versus richard
spencer because like
to to to challa is that his name he's
all like it's our country our borders we
can't let anybody in
he even says in the movie like if they
come in here they'll bring their
problems with them
and so it was very much it was like
ethno-nationalist country hoarding its
wealth
but then the bad guy was like we should
give weapons to everyone of our race and
like take over the world so it's like
who is the good guy in that movie i
guess at the end t'challa goes to one of
the wealthiest nations in the world
and goes to one of the richest cities in
california and gives
people stuff i just thought that was
really hilarious they were like they
decided to open up their country to help
people
so he goes to what do you go to oakland
it's like i get oakland's got problems
but like it's still the bay area you
know what i mean like
it's still pretty wealthy anyway we were
talking about voting
and i was going to talk about this
evidence and then we got sidetracked
yeah can i interject something here that
just came up on my phone
so it looks like georgia's uh finished
their hand audit and they have confirmed
it for
biden and the other thing i have on my
phone is that the ap
has declared joe biden the winner in
georgia after the state election office
said that the hand tally about well you
know maybe it's all over and donald
trump's going to not be president
there you go that's what i thought yeah
16.
as of 2016 yeah and then he was
president yeah and now
i don't know i kind of feel like we're
gonna have two presidents
you know what though i don't i wonder if
you get the same feeling
do you think trump voters would be as
angry as the left if
they lost no but i feel like that's and
there's been surveys about that
because we're just like oh well that
sucks yeah most people
but i also think that the the die-hard
trump supporters especially the people
over at like say like the donald
win are much more i don't the right word
is fervent
yeah they're uh like joe biden is going
to destroy this country
he's going to he's going to enforce the
lockdowns fauci is saying normalcy won't
return for a year
and what's happening is all the big box
stores and the big corporations are
getting all this money their stock value
is skyrocketing
and small mom and pop shops are being
destroyed and joe biden says
you know i'll lock down if they say to
and then osterholm who's the guy who
says to that advisor to biden says oh
we're gonna lock the whole country
down and then fauci goes no no no
no no we're not gonna lock the whole
country down
but there will be lockdowns and we won't
return to normal until quarter quarter
two or quarter three
that's going to wipe out small business
yeah it's going to destroy the economy
of this country
and leave us very very
uh worse off to put it mildly it's won't
do that trump do the opposite
yeah i mean none of us can know the
future but it's interesting to think
like
all right so even in my area where
there's a lot of chain businesses
they're closing most of their stores too
yeah they just
i don't know the money's not coming in
people don't want to work there anymore
um who knows what kind of is everything
going to be delivering nowadays like
amazon yeah yeah they both buy your
amazon i guess sure
and you know god knows i've been using
them too but like it's
i i need to go outside for my own health
i go shopping just to go out shopping i
put on stupid mouths so you're trying to
kill grandma it's what you're saying
maybe it's it's too bad that
they're so humans are not built for
being in pods and uh
i feel like uh depending on how
conspiratorial i want to be i
i can feel alex jones's energy in the
seat oh yeah it's just
maybe this is like a test and they're
trying to see how far you can push
humans into society and like see can you
keep them
in their houses and see what happens i
see the tin foil right there yeah
but but they we know they're talking
about the great reset
we know that they've been advocating for
all year or longer than this the book i
think was written in 1996
by claude schwab and uh it was like
earlier this year they were like we need
a great reset
now they're basically saying we gotta
lock everything down even though it's
not proven to do anything at all
like we locked down nothing happened
everything got worse right okay so
lockdowns clearly don't make sense
and it seems like it just makes it just
fits with the grace
great reset plans it sounds like they've
said covet 19 is their opportunity to do
this
they're telling us literally what
they're doing yeah coveted 19 popped up
and they said
all right let's do it let's uh let's
let's use this as a pretext for a
lockdown to destroy wealth and ownership
because one of the goals of the great
reset is that people won't own anything
what's going to end up happening is this
there's gonna be like a 45 year old dude
who owned his own you know hardware shop
he goes out of business completely now
he owns nothing then they're going to
make you dependent upon the government
with these stimulus packages
and then all that money is going to go
to amazon and we're going to have like
three major corporations that supplies
with our goods
yeah well whether or not that was
intentional that certainly seems to be
what's going to happen if we keep going
down this track
um some people want to stop it we maybe
you know some people who have read a few
books say hey
maybe we shouldn't go down this
direction this is where it could go
maybe we should kind of slow the train
down if we can
maybe i don't know hedge our bets that's
why i like the idea of states all having
their own rules we shouldn't do this
whole federal i don't like
joe biden's plan of across the whole
country we all have to wear masks
every state every even county has
different rules
depending on density of population
density and well there lies the big
problem for a great reset
republicans saying no we won't lock down
and democrats saying yes there's no
uniformity
how can you have a great reset when
there's a constitution and
states getting involved you can't
yeah like a mediocre reset yeah
yeah i'm a fan of states rights i don't
like the idea of uh
the federal government swinging it's uh
uh
what's the word mandatory mandate so
here's here's what i'm doing
giant mandatory mandate here's my
current thought process
all right here you go uh i think it was
just after the election i said like
that night media is going to call it for
biden trump is going to overturn
the courts then they're going to say
trump stole the election it's a very
simple prediction
that just fits with like a lot of what's
going on and i don't think it was that
spectacular but all these lefties are
like dude
so dumb you think trump's gonna win and
i'm like i think yeah absolutely i think
it's possible and
there's a vox and atlantic and nbc have
all written about trump's
you know path now they're starting to
get scared and the propaganda's getting
crazy
reuters is like trump's latest scheme to
steal the win from joe biden and i'm
like but joe biden didn't win
like our are we we're not a popular vote
country
so like this idea that if the electoral
vote votes for trump trump didn't win
it's like no he literally did that's how
the constitution works
and if he finds a legal path to do it
but now they're writing stuff like crazy
so here's what here's what i'm worried
about right now
they already called it for joe biden
like crazy twitter's putting labels
everywhere
joe biden is the president-elect he's
not
literally not until he's certified but
you know until the electoral votes are
cast usually calling someone
president-elect is just like
it's it's it's like a placeholder an
honorary title
no it's like it's a tradition we just do
it because the other person conceded and
so we're like sure find it to you we get
it
give them some briefings you know yeah
but that's not the constitutional
process
the constitutional process is we on the
14th they'll make their vote
so for biden and the media to be like
claiming this over and over again and
refusing to back down
is quite literally them refusing to
accept the the
the process for the election it's a
conspiracy although
i wouldn't no it could be a standalone
complex but they're all conspiring to
make him the president
to make him seem like the
president-elect could be complex but you
have a bunch of people
coming together who said they came
together well they're all saying the
same thing standalone complex
right do you remember the difference a
standalone complex is when people do
something
uh oh i see they'll do this a similar
thing but they're not like behind the
scenes
being like hey let's do this together so
they're all saying joe biden won
because they want joe biden to win and
it makes it look like a concerted effort
when it's just a bunch of people doing
the same thing at the same time
so that's that's more likely but
regardless what do you think is going to
happen
when you have the for weeks joe biden
won joe biden one ap says he won ap says
he won
and trump's like we're going to court
the the governor of arizona is like he's
we're not going to accept this until we
get the legal resolution that's the in
the constitution
trump is going through this in the
constitutional process whether he wins
or not is not the point
the media is lying refusing to accept
the process
in of our government by coming out and
saying joe biden is the president-elect
they are literally
undermining the constitution and our
legal process that's crazy
and they're and they keep pumping up
more and more propaganda so i think what
scares me right now i don't i don't know
what the probability this happens maybe
it does maybe it doesn't
maybe it's a lottery tickets chance
maybe it's lightning striking three
times while a shark jumps in the air
maybe donald trump overturns a few
states
they get frozen joe biden doesn't have
270 electoral votes
and then the electoral college uh
can't deliver so it goes to house
delegation the delegations are
republican for the most part they're
majority republicans so they vote for
trump
then trump comes out and says i've won
then all these democrats say no you
didn't
joe biden and he says look at the court
look at the electoral college look at
the delegations look at the supreme
court
then they're going to say trump is
illegitimate he didn't win and we know
it and trump's going to say i am
legitimate i won and everyone knows it
and then the trump supporters going to
say trump is right and the anti-trump
people are going to say trump is
stealing the election
and then what do you think happens well
i don't even think they need to do that
i think they
people have been winding themselves up
for long enough already
that if you were to tell biden
supporters that he didn't actually win
or antifa they would throw a fit they
would freak out but i think berg out
i think in order for there to actually
so i'm not saying it's gonna happen
but the worst case scenario would be and
it's been a lot of people were saying
we're gonna get the scenario where both
declare they won
and we're already there now trump is
saying i won the election we'll prove it
but we're not it's not official for
either so
so biden can say i'm the president-elect
and people roll their eyes trump can say
i have one and the left laughs
but what happens when trump is certified
but the media declares biden and all
these people don't know
i was talking to a friend earlier and i
said it looks like trump's plans are
working to some degree
like this this challenge in in michigan
that might block up the certification
i'm not saying he's going to win and she
said what is this i'm not seeing any of
this
i'm not seeing any of this news so you
get people
who can't see any of this happening
because all they get fed is cnn
and cnn says it's over so they believe
it you're going to end up with
trump's going to be like i won and
they're going to be like but he didn't
win
the news said it was biden and they're
not going to actually look at the
electoral college results they're not
going to actually look at the supreme
court they're
going to have no idea because cnn's
going to be like he didn't win nope he's
lying
it seems really irresponsible for trump
and biden both to be saying that they
won
when the the constitutionally neither of
them yes
are they both are they idiots are they
both stupid
well biden i think trump is doing it
strategically but it's a lie he's the
president he's lying
i think trump is doing it because biden
declared himself the victor so trump
responded he lied i'm gonna lie
too well it's just such an irresponsible
terrible thing for someone to do
joe biden they declared joe biden the
winner then joe biden said he won
and so trump had to push back well why
didn't he just say he didn't win where
it's under constitutional review yeah
yeah
yep so am i crazy though because he
trump is president until january 20th
period
not according to facebook sorry you're
wrong okay according to facebook
facebook says you're right that sign
then
he is president but he didn't win the
election yet his character as such is
that he doesn't like being undermined so
if someone raises the volume to 10 he
has to raise it to 11
and there is a certain point where once
you're past 11
you can't shout it's like an internet
fighting match if someone's like
yo fight me bro and the other guy's like
hey man i'm gonna fight you
all right where are you living where's
your house let's fight
you can only fight so hard online until
it comes to
fisticuffs until a guy shows up at your
house right so
in a way what we're seeing between the
two president uh
candidates is an online shouting match
of
come at me bro yeah yeah and it's not
going to end in a fist fight with them
but it's going to be their supporters
having fist fights as we saw on the
street
the institutional powers have declared
joe biden the winner
that's so irresponsible i don't want to
overuse that word
this is crazy jake tapper responded to
trump trump said something like
you know we're suing or whatever jake
tapper said
donald trump's refusal to accept the the
loss
you know blah blah and i'm just like for
jake tapper this
per this high profile personality on cnn
to completely disregard the constitution
is just like one of the most dangerous
things a media personality can do
either the guy is really really dumb or
he's
it's malicious so is jake tapper trying
to purposefully undermine the
constitution in our system of governance
the idea that we have an election and
then that night we go we know who won
is just a tradition getting to the point
where i don't care if he
knows he's undermining the constitution
or not he is he's undermining the
constitution right
at some point in our history probably
with the invention of tv or maybe even
radio we stopped saying
the official results will be announced
on the 14th and we started saying
this is it we know who won and so and so
conceded well
that's fine and i got no problem with
that but donald trump didn't concede
so the race isn't over we don't know
who's won we don't know which slate of
electors will be going to dc for their
you know formal
election it's not happened yet so for
the media to be saying all this stuff
is completely spitting on the
constitution and saying we don't care
about the process
it's a fact that trump is supposed to be
filing legal claims up until like the
eighth of december it's
in in the constitution for this reason
these are safeguards to prevent
you know fraud or impropriety or
whatever so trump's allowed to do it
and the media doesn't like it they don't
like the fact that he has
the right to challenge it they're
flexing they want to see how far their
influence
can i mean even back when obama they had
no reason to complain during the obama
years
during bush i remember i was oh he was
blowing up kids so they were happy you
know
well i mean all right so when we were
we're about the same age i think when we
were in high school
they were just making fun of bush all
the time then 911 happened and they
you know started the wars and all that
stuff and they kept criticizing bush
criticizing bush calling him names
making fun of him
fine they were swinging their influence
around just to say like hey look we're
controlling
the we're the mediators between the
people and the
uh governing bodies whatever so
they'll believe whatever we say we
whatever we tell them to believe
a journalist let's say is in a position
where
i'll listen to the journalists more than
i'll listen to a politician and trump is
the first time where the people are
listening to the politicians so closely
at least for in our generation they're
listening they're going directly to the
source there's no more middleman
so the middleman cnn and all those
people are feeling themselves lose power
so they have to make it seem like this
is an emergency guys
my connection to you is like my psychic
link to you is being weakened
you need my words of wisdom in your ear
don't listen to that man who you have to
feel it's like that time
when the um when hillary's emails linked
leaked and then the i can't remember who
was it tapper or was it judo
you can't read them yeah it's illegal
for your eagle only we can read that one
you have to it's like bro it's like in
the old church
like way in the old days the priests
would be like you can't read the bible
yourself i have to interpret it for you
i'll tell you what the bible says so
maybe he's fudging what the bible really
says
but then when the printing press was
invented and now the commoners can read
the bible it's like wait
this is what the bible says bro i gotta
give you how much money right
the internet really is like the printing
press all over again right and of course
the
the the priest equivalents of today
let's say cnn are now realizing oh shoot
uh the common person can go directly to
the source of power without me
filtering the words filtering what i
want reality to be
they feel themselves losing power and
they the only way to
get people's attention again is to
create a crisis
you have to listen to what i have to say
it's so important
don't listen to the other guy well to
quote chancellor suttler
i want them to know why they need us
yeah who's he
from v for vendetta um i want it on the
interlink every
story whatever you know you have to it's
like
i get up in the morning what should i do
today what should i be worried about
i should tune in to cnn and make sure
it's safe to go outside
even even me coming here i'm not going
to say specifics but it's like
i didn't even know what route to take
because
is is this place covid infested which
where's the safe direction to go am i
asking cnn did you turn on cnn and say
oh anderson please
i punched it into the intertron oh yes
and then it's like
did you find the answer i did because
this is such a remote location actually
a spirit guide
you showed me on an eagle i followed
facebook face and the moon appeared and
looked down and said turn left because
google maps gonna start putting covet
friendly zones on your
they already do so what really i was
going every time i go to the doctor
they're like covered 19 alert copy 19
alert you have to have a mask
like is it like some of the roads are
green when there's covid in that area
like that this area has the miasma don't
go yeah yeah
do you guys see the uh ticketmaster is
saying that they're going to put your
vaccination status in the ticket or
whatever
oh jeez goodbye ticketmaster okay no
all right the nosebleed section will be
the uh the dirty people
who didn't take it exactly they're not
gonna let you in no i think what's gonna
end up happening is
you know if they made fun of
anti-vaxxers for a long time now they're
saying anti-maskers
because it's meant to be like you know
an uh
like similar and so right now they're
saying dude just wear the mask man it's
not a big deal and even i'm saying it
like i got no problem look i go to the
store i'll wear masks whatever
that's different then they're gonna
start saying dude just get the vacs man
it's no big deal
and so they're gonna make everyone get
the vaccine i mean in some places
they've already done it so i'm not
trying to like be conspiratorial like oh
the mandatory vaccination's coming
there's there have been uh i think in
australia you can't travel outside of
the country unless you've been
vaccinated something like that
in denmark they're protesting a law
right now they've been protesting for
like 10 or 11 days
man a law that includes a provision for
mandatory vaccination and forced
physical examinations
so probably a good thing to protest
because that's
freaky well here's what i think it'll
come here i do what if
it doesn't mutate every year like the
flu let's say so every year you have to
get a new vaccination
or is that gas is that the plan i don't
know i don't have a plan no we don't
know i don't know anything about this
we have a great reset plan that's true i
don't take away all your stuff i mean
maybe a state will be like you can't
come in if you didn't get the vaccine
but that'd be like the governor made
that decision and then the people would
riot
on the governor i think we're going to
see riots again i think the riots we saw
this year in june were a product uh a
bit
of being locked up for so long dude
there's so much data of recovery rates
for kovid
that people would go insane if they
tried to do some forced
dude look at like we were just talking
about people cheering for trunan on a
shot of pressure
the mindless yeah maybe maybe that was
part what what if trinidad shabbat of
the pressure was actually in joe biden's
like uh teleprompter and it was them
being like okay
if they cheer for this we can do
anything
and so biden is like you know what
people don't realize mine's actually
sharp as attack right
he was actually able to read true do not
shop at a pressure on the teleprompter
as it moves up give me something crazy
that took me a long
time to transcribe to get it just right
trued it on a shop at a pressure
and so for him to be able to read it off
real quick what was it again true
international cooperation cooperation i
don't know if that's i'm just
no idea true international cooperation
under pressure
and what's batacath care healthcare what
was that
obamacare
if you've got 77 million people or
whatever in this country
and a large portion are such zealots
that they'll
cheer when when joe biden says garbled
nonsense just wants someone to be trump
they're gonna be like drink this
substance from under my basement
upstairs they're not gonna come into my
restaurant
zealots aren't necessarily the kovitz
zealots they are
well not necessarily they might there
might be some overlapping heavy overlap
so we were talking to michael malus on
the show and
it was on the show we mentioned what is
it how do you determine left or right
yeah yeah
no i think it was before the show was it
yeah i think so oh okay
it was on the show yeah yeah it was okay
okay he said i made a speech
yeah that's right right you started yeah
he said uh how do you figure out
someone's on the left or right you ask
them
do you think some people are better than
others and the right will say yes and
the left will give you a speech i was
like defined better
yeah yeah i think i think that's what i
said to you yeah there's an easier way
to do it
it's to ask someone are they scared of
covid
and for the most part the right's going
to be like no you know i get it
it's you know a lot of people will be
like a lot of the like the the
you know the die-hard guys are going to
be like no way man i don't have to wear
a man i can do whatever i want
then you're going to get the more
moderate people who are going to say
look i get it it's like it's got
lingering health effects it's serious
i'll wear my mask but i'm not going to
go cry i'm going to you know carry on
with my life
the left that you look at the gallup
polls from this
it's like something like 70 of
republicans are like we're kind of
concerned about this
and uh five percent of democrats are
like we're kind of concerned the rest of
them are like it's the end
like 95 of democrats are freaking out
over this i i
respect and fear to appoint dangerous
pathogens
and things i completely because they can
ravage animals
quickly but there's so much evidence
that covet has what 99.9
99.9 now that's even more uh recovery
rate so it's like people are getting it
unless you're over 70 or have a
comorbidity then it's 90 uh 97.5 and
that's because of the cobalt 97 points
that's still great for someone with
comorbidity that's old that's a high
death rate though that's like you know a
couple percent
point is seriously sad but those people
were already ill a lot of those are
over seven years in the community right
right right they have comorbidities and
and when you see numbers like that i'm
just not
concerned i'm not even concerned so you
know what's weird i'm sorry no go ahead
good
it's a weird reversal because weren't
conservatives considered the types to be
like putting up fences closing their
doors putting
like turtles going into their shell
right protective
whereas now we're seeing liberals saying
no now we have to
or leftists i should say now we have to
uh put our shells on and close up
and conservatives are saying let's open
up and check this out
in minnesota in the iron range two
long time uh like leaders in the
democratic party have quit
it's the democratic farmer labor party
or whatever they call the democratic
party
in minnesota they quit and they said
because we want to make a more moderate
bipartisan
you know party or whatever in caucus so
the republicans are like glad to hear it
because the democrats have gone nuts in
minnesota
the democrats gained areas that were
typically republican
affluent suburbs and trump gained in the
working-class areas and that's
so weird it's a flip the the the
democratic party has become the party of
the wealthy elites and the managerial
elites
and the moral authoritarians and the
republican parties become the party of
not completely but the shift is
happening blue-collar-ish blue-collar
just regular working people that's weird
because i'll go through neighborhoods
around where i live and
i see a lot of mansions with the biden
signs and then i see
a lot of like carpenter types of people
uh people who work with their hands
they love trump right blue collar people
we're living in backwards land it's
flipped i don't know what's going on
with 2020. you look at you look at like
the ultra woke people
that's typically like a wealthy they're
typically upper class progressive
they have a lot to lose if the rioters
come down their street they have a lot
of those
interesting i think the flip is coming
it's getting crazier and crazier and
maybe that's all that needs to happen
and there's not going to be some like
chaotic civil war or something
but my my bigger fear is is trump
if we get to a point where there is some
kind of court certification for trump
giving him a legal justification to say
he won
and then biden refuses to admit defeat
and i think it's very likely hillary
clinton said
joe biden should not concede under any
circumstances now to be real
like realistic trump is the one who is
protected to lose right now i'm not
trying to do this stupid like but
hillary can still win
no but trump is still suing and there's
still these like really narrow paths
where he might actually figure something
out
and if he does joe biden's not gonna
back down i'm worried about whether
if this is a silly chess game let's say
there's only so many ways that could go
if things turn violent
you get the military involved that
creates bad optics which creates more
anti-authoritarian sentiment which
creates more violence
rights exactly there's no good outcome
for that
if i was the type of person who says
that's what i want chaotic situations
where
they're begging for the government the
right is going to be begging for the
government to intercede
which looks bad and is bad because
you're going to see people getting their
heads caved in by like police officers
who are angry or
national guard or something like that on
the other hand if you just let the
rioters go crazy like they have been
who knows what kind of damage is going
to be done people are going to be scared
to go outside
we're sort of backing ourselves because
the temperature is so high
we're all backing ourselves into these
bad corners where there's really no way
out
except either bad optics people getting
their heads caved in violence
i wish this this could be solved on a
legislative level on let's use our words
but everybody seems to be so scared of
the other side and
in some cases for good reason i don't
want to talk to somebody who's coming at
me with like a shield and a thing in
their hand like
bro put it down you see that uh
california regional democrat who says we
need to deprogram
75 million americans and then the
responses were like this is why they
have gulags
so the crazy thing about it is this guy
thinks literally all 75 million
trump supporters are like fanatical
conspiracy
like psychopaths running around
screaming when in fact
the overwhelming majority of trump's
voters are probably like some dude who
was like who should i
vote for well trump seems to be for
unions and then that's it
he's been doing fine that's why i voted
for him is he's fine
i don't i don't see any reason to change
it there's a lot of people who voted for
trump who are like not political
yeah so so when you know when you see
these videos of like the q anon people
or like the really die-hard trumpers
that's a small fraction of trump's base
yeah they're they're vocal there's
there's many of them it's probably in
the millions
but most trump supporters are probably
just like i don't know man you know i
think trump's going to do better with
the economy
i didn't get a 600 fine for not having
obamacare so exactly
you did no i didn't yeah trump's in
office i know
yeah that's why i didn't appreciate that
at all i was
already broke i didn't want to sign up
for it right so i get fined
it's like bro you're you're stealing
money out of my pocket i'm just this
poor
yup i'm already poor yeah i can and i
don't want to sign up for things like
this it's
uh i didn't it disagreed with me morally
uh
i i don't i don't feel like i should
reach in other people's pockets and take
money out of there and i mean that's
what taxes are i suppose some people
could argue but
yeah it is and and to varying degrees
you know
i was looking at a chart i think it's
only the one percent for the most part
that pays taxes
most uh most people in this country
under a certain
uh income they pay taxes but they
receive
more from the government more value more
monetary value than they actually pay is
that including like
roads and yeah fire departments like
every every every benefit you get
is a net negative for the government
except for the rich people who are
paying
progressively more taxes yeah okay well
that sounds functional
yeah right that sounds really i mean and
the problem is the left response is
tax the rich and it's like okay where
how much
like what percentage like what are we
talking about and then you hear about
this plan for like a wealth tax
it sounds to me like it's too much
coming from the left the progressives
that is literally just them saying burn
the country to the ground
plus the panama papers did you guys
study those at all when those came out
a little bit that was a while ago it was
like all the people out there offshore
money yeah in panama and other places
but there's
lots of rich people will just store
their money over offshore especially if
you start to tax them hard
they'll put it into assets overseas
illegally hide it yeah
yeah they can start you can start a
company in a different country to have
your money
your income go into and then you don't
got to pay taxes on it it's crazy
arguably you do
but like these people find these
loopholes it's like a bad bad chess game
we're far
worked way too far both sides are losing
and
if you were analyzing the game you have
to say okay around turn
20 everything went bad for both of us we
lost all our pieces
we're just going around our kings are
circling each other can we just restart
can we rewind the game can't you gotta
call it stalemate no no no
it's not it's it's not about at turn 20
something so things went wrong it's
about
at a certain point the democrats decided
repealing the civil rights law in
california was a good idea
would you would you ever like would you
compromise if if like so the democrats
were like look
the we want to repeal civil rights laws
notably this one in california
and and give the government the right to
discriminate in the basis of race
will you compromise maybe would you
would you be okay if we only
discriminated on the basis of certain
races
no you would would you compromise at all
with that position or would you say
civil rights law must remain they've
been you don't you say like give them an
inch they take a foot you know something
like that giving you take a mile
right it's they've been doing it for a
long time it's just maybe now
they're bolder with their demands we've
i say we but they've been getting their
way for a very long time
now they feel more bold and just saying
you know what i'm going to take the
whole table i'm not going to just take
this one piece of cake
well the issue i see is cause i was
talking to my friend and she was saying
like we got to figure out a way to bring
people together and like
move forward as a country and i was like
i completely agree so if you can figure
out a way
to convince the people who want to
repeal civil rights law in california it
failed by the way because the people of
california voted against it
if you can figure out a way to convince
them to stop doing that then i think
we'll have unity
but you can't because they're saying
you're the racist for allowing these
anti-discrimination laws well they've
been doing it anyway on
on your say i ran an application i want
to work for
tim incorporated and there's a little
line that says uh if you want to
write down your race and gender here and
if i choose not to answer those that
means i'm one of those pesky people with
opinions
you're not going to hire me so they've
they've had those lines in the
applications i've tried to work in the
animation industry and stuff like that
so i know these things
i'm a genius uh so i'm just kidding but
never serious they have they have softly
been screening for
this kind of thing for many years that
just so happened that they felt bold
enough to put it now into law
the companies have been doing it forever
well so the issue though is
there is such a fundamental difference
right now between the two
realities there is no compromise but you
can compromise on some things probably
but some of the stuff they're proposing
is just so downright psychotic
it's like you're you're not going to
compromise on that and that and
you can't bring people together when you
have like that story in texas where the
dad says his kid is not trans and the
mom says the kid
is and the mom wants to put the kid on
you know treatment and medical treatment
which can permanently alter the kid for
the rest of his life
that's like there's no middle ground
there i think we need to think of it as
religious in religious terms like we're
looking at
we say religion is like follow this book
but really it's like a set of rules it's
like an operating system perhaps you can
put it that way
some people have mac installed some
people have windows installed
you got in this case the mom had mac or
pc whatever
the dad had the other operating system
links
completely yeah we think completely
differently uh the human mind maybe is
just a computer without an operating
system installed but we're taught to
say okay we're going to view the world
okay in china this is what the world is
like this is what is right and wrong
this is how you should behave in other
countries maybe they're more religious
they say
this is the operating system we're going
to install in your head and for some
people maybe the operating system
is more deeply installed in other cases
maybe you lose your religion something
like that but we have a sort of form of
secularism devotion to the state perhaps
depending on okay let's say if uh if
someone says i stand for x
y and z they are told oh then you're in
this party
therefore you have to believe all these
other things because you're on our team
now
right i don't like being on a team i
just i i kind of buffet style this is
what i believe here
maybe i'll change i believe a little bit
of this but obviously
well so like uh one one another issue
another example is
do you know how many unarmed black men
were shot and killed by police last year
i remember you saying it was like 20
says i'll give you i'll give you the
high end
13. yeah the low end is nine depending
on which source you use
13. when i hear that i say it does not
sound like after 375 million
interactions between police and and you
know civilians
that we have a widespread or systemic
problem with police targeting
you know people of color or something
like that but black lives matter
believes they do so they go out and they
riot
it feels higher to them i would say well
i mean it's a media issue
i've got a friend who he always jokes he
used to joke about uh
being pulled over for driving while
black he would say
things like that he's terrified of the
police and he i'm sure he's heard
stories about people getting beaten up
or whatever
bad story and could that be what's
driving it that fear story just the
stories
they're afraid of understandably police
being
cruel to them i get it when i was i i
hear all this talk this these stories
about the talk right
yeah where they say like you know they
say black families have to give their
kids the talk about how to deal with
cops
and the weirdest thing to me is like i
went through that talk yeah like my dad
sat me down and said we have a
discussion about what you do when you're
stopped by the police and
i was like maybe i guess we're you know
we are a mixed race family from south
side of chicago so maybe that's it we're
not the privileged white people from the
suburbs i guess
but i hear a ton of people of different
races who have the talk
but for some reason the median narrative
makes it specifically about you know
only black people
but i'm not trying to get into the whole
black lives matter thing i'm bringing up
just to say
the fundamental world view is completely
is
is divergent there's no there's no
bringing that together
so you end up with people marching
through the streets smashing things
burning things down and destroying
things
and when i say hey you shouldn't do that
they say you need to understand their
pain it's like well i
i'm not going to compromise with that
there's no amount of writing i'm going
to say that's
that's the okay amount one way you can
think of it is i like this metaphor
about each of us having our own
operating system and certain people have
a different operating system than you do
so you've got linux they've got windows
and
certain mined viruses can only infect
you if you're running a specific type of
operating system
so this mine virus that's making those
people crazy only affects their
operating systems
it doesn't affect you and you're
incapable of understanding the virus
because it doesn't
it doesn't function with your operating
system so in order for you to understand
what they're going through
you're going to have to install windows
no that's that's that's that's not the
announcement at least in like a boot
camp i know exactly what they think they
think that
as they've said that police are hunting
down black people
and that's just mathematically not
possible only
it's just not true there's probably
instances of profiling
that's a fact their racism absolutely
exists their racist cops these things
happen
but to go out and burn down for white
progressives to go to black
neighborhoods and burn these buildings
down
is that a matter of me not getting it i
understand why they're angry and they're
wrong
so there's no level where i compromise
it's an emotional thing the issue is not
about whether or not i understand them
the issue is flat out like
i reject them burning down black
businesses in atlanta
i reject it outright and i will not
compromise with it i think so there's no
bringing these two groups together when
one says that they believe they have the
right
white progressives to go to atlanta and
destroy and burn down black
black businesses you see those rappers i
forgot the guy's name where he was like
why are you doing this to us
and they just don't give they don't care
at all and so i say i reject the
destruction that they bring upon these
communities
and that makes me right-wing and they're
left-wing there is no point at which i
sit down and i say
so tell me what you want to burn down
next okay what if you only burn down
half that's never going to happen you
got to understand
why they feel that way i know why they
feel that way because the media lies to
them and because they have no idea
what's really going on
that's not that's not the issue though
the issue is if someone believes
they have a right to do something and i
believe that they don't
and they're wrong there is no us coming
together
the divergent realities cannot co-exist
and it's leading to street violence
and it's leading to mass media
propaganda and like the media just
puts out garbage fake stories because it
makes them money they rile up these
people into believing crazy things for
crazy reasons
and then if you come out and say that's
not true you're right wing
for example one of the categories for
there's something called transparency
tube
that like charts who's left and who's
right
if you believe that uh bret cat they
lied about brett kavanaugh you're
right-wing
if you if you believe that you know if
you talk about migrant caravans
and you're critical in any capacity
you're right-wing is it a website called
transparency yeah and it charts all
these different
youtube channels it's right-wing to say
they
they lied about brett kavanaugh because
the right
tribe says this is crazy and the left
tribe says brett kavanaugh
is you know a gang abuser so that's
that's clearly brett kavanaugh is not he
was vetted to become a federal judge
that was clearly not true
the woman had no evidence none of it was
corroborated but they go
nuts on that and nothing on hunter biden
so your right wing you say
wow hunter biden clearly did something
and brett kavanaugh didn't that's right
wing
so how do you compromise someone sits
down and says okay
we will allow hunter biden to be
arrested for his transgressions but
we're also going to arrest brett
kavanaugh for being a gang abuser
you're going to be like but brett
kavanaugh didn't do that well we got to
compromise right
no it's not going to happen there's not
going to be a compromise between those
positions
that's because you cannot compromise
about truth and it comes down to what is
true and what is not
and they live you ever see that meme
where it's like a square
from one angle but the other angle the
edges are rounded so it looks like a
circle
and then you see the shadows on the wall
and both shadows are right
they're both true but one person sees
square one two guys
looking at a six and a nine yeah well
it's very very similar so truth is
relative to how you perceive the
situation
well no there are people who believe
they know the truth based on limited
information but some things are just
true
i i don't so the the the uh available
body of evidence on say brett kavanaugh
would not
bring us to a position beyond a
reasonable doubt that brett kavanaugh
did anything wrong
there's just no evidence in fact there's
evidence of the contrary
her friends were saying they don't
recall what she's talking about and they
don't think they even knew brett
yet she still carried on the democrats
still said he did it
and now there and now you still have the
left saying i can't believe that
that rapist is now on the supreme court
it's like they never presented literally
any evidence
the only evidence that came out was that
she was probably lying about some things
like when she said
she was scared to fly and then she was
asked didn't you fly to like the bahamas
or something and she goes yes
okay like i thought you were scared to
fly apparently not
so they they they have no no leg to
stand on but they just believe it
it's the truna shabat of pressure phenom
i'm to call it that
true it's the true nanasha pressure
phenomenon
where the left will just cheer for
anything so long as it's blue
period they don't want to be afraid
anymore i think but at the very bottom
even beneath the operating system thing
i think just
on the humans as an organism can't stand
to be afraid for too long they will
jump on any they say there's that saying
any port in a storm
i don't want to be afraid anymore hey
government hey tv hey cnn just tell me
something so that i don't have to be
afraid anymore tell me what i need to do
or say do i need to go enchant with this
group of people over here fine i just
don't want to be afraid anymore
you for instance kavanaugh i feel like
they're not attacking him as a person
they don't know him as a person
but they're attacking the symbol the
symbol of a right-leaning judge
in a majority possible well now it's a
majority
a right-leaning majority that means that
it will take away
certain freedoms from them that they
value more than
their own safety and the safety of
others they will become violent because
they are
convinced that that symbol being in a
position of power means
their lives and other lives will be
ruined they're afraid of what will
happen so they have to attack
the symbol they're attacking trump but
they're not really attacking trump
they're attacking
what he symbolizes well the media
painted him as this this image
well that's why they loved him before he
ran
or he was a funny yeah he was funny
before but now he's in a position of
power
that's very scary people don't want to
be scared so then ultimately the issue
is
we have two divergent realities one
where the media just
ignores the constitution and says joe
biden won when he didn't and he probably
it looks like he's on track two when
that's fine but we're nowhere near that
point we're a month
away from an actual winner in this
in the traditional constitutional
process the media just doesn't care so
now you have one side saying
let the process play out we're still
waiting it's like but the other side's
saying it's not true and all these
people just believe it
there's divergent realities and so the
idea that we could come together to me
seems just not possible regarding the
people that would give up
their freedom and that seek safety or
freedom i think that's literally like a
thomas jefferson quote it might have
been jefferson
sure uh those that are willing to give
up their freedom i think safety is
incorrectly attributed to ben franklin
franklin deserve neither safety nor
freedom what
who is both yeah who who was that
attributed to was that
i think it was falsely attributed to ben
franklin but i don't know the origin of
it
but basically if you give up your
freedom for security you're going to
lose all of it
those that would be storming into your
house and dragging your wife out by your
hair and looking for the
the noise behind the tv it's you don't
want to give up your freedom
okay that was the idea it's like saying
what what words what prayer do i have to
say do i have to go to confession i
don't mean to speak against religion
some religions are very good i think but
what do i have to say or
do do i have to give money like a candle
whatever to just make the guilt of the
pain
the the the fear go away just tell me oh
priest
or tell me oh group what do i need to do
to make it go away there's something
very deep in the organism of humans
that's beneath culture it's just the
whole organism of humans
we need to go to an external source
because i think we punish ourselves a
lot
with with fear and guilt and sort of uh
for instance if i'm if i grow up in a
really rich family i have a certain
guilt
i didn't but let's say i feel a certain
guilt because i had certain privileges
that other people don't
i can then be convinced by let's say a
very charismatic person
that hey i grew up with all these
privileges therefore i should feel
guilty
and therefore i should give away
everything i have and then serve
a certain group of people that i think
are underprivileged
which could be a good thing that can
make my guilt go away that's a
potentially good thing
but if you apply that to a certain
ideology that says
all people who are doing well are evil
and are stealing
you are now taking that guilt and
turning it you're almost weaponizing it
people can be converted because of guilt
feelings they can be converted into
weapons which i
we've seen with the communists and
socialism i can understand why
on its surface it seems attractive but
when you see
there's that saying you can know a tree
by its fruit when you see what happens
years down the road to these countries
no the gulag archipelago for instance
you see what happens to
anyone who's doing better than anyone
else they are now a target because
clearly they they stole it they took
advantage of somebody else
so anytime i'm doing better than the guy
next to me
i have to feel guilty and then that
person has
a an advantage over me of like a moral
superiority
i'm be i'm below that person they're
doing better than me therefore
uh i don't know communism is what i can
get away with stealing from him so for
instance you'll see
uh the rioters and the looting they'll
someone once told me um
it's okay to steal from like walmart
because you know they're doing so well
as
because they steal from their workers
right and it doesn't matter you're still
stealing that's the point you're
breaking the law and
lawlessness leads to all kinds of like
other problems and there's a million
reasons not to do it it's wrong
but they're justifying it and saying
that person was not doing well off
when you start excusing
what we're calling it crime when you
excuse it
you start going into all these things of
like well if i just turn the other way
well some guy got clubbed over the head
but he deserved it i'm sure he deserved
it so so
uh why did they come after you let's
talk about the the reddit stuff
sure um so first tell us the story and
then we'll talk about what why it
happened
i'm really bad at telling the story so i
forgive please forgive me but
so on reddit i drew a series of comics
that did really well
uh in terms of votes the way that reddit
works if anyone doesn't know
you get upvotes and down votes upvotes
means everybody likes your thing your
post and
lots of if you get a score of zero that
means lots of people downloaded it
so i drew a series of comics back in
december of 2018.
long story short one of them they kept
getting better and better
scores until one of them hit the
all-time record
um and then the next comic i drew after
that oh well the comic was about
the mob going after comics creators i
have a
certain comics friend who was raped
raked over the coals
by the mob and they all enjoyed uh
taking him down so the joke was that
hey come be our new king so i the
new king of reddit comics would
sit on this new throne but his dead body
with spears
that were upvote arrows we're going
through him
and it's like okay we're going to get
rid of his body and you can come sit
on the throne and be our new comics king
so the next comic after that was i was
sitting there staring at the
crowd and i'm thinking okay so how do i
entertain these people
and i drew as the punch line uh the hand
circle game
and if anyone doesn't know the hand
circle game is i i guess won't show it
but
okay hand sign yeah it's yeah it's the
upside down though so it's
the joke being like i'll put it beneath
my belt and if you look at it then i get
to punch you
in the shoulder of course so it was an
anti uh joke
it's like i have no joke therefore i'm
gonna play the hand circle game with
everyone on reddit hey i get to punch
you all on the shoulder
right that was my punch line but they
interpreted it as the okay hand symbol
which was
prevalent at the time especially and
still is they saw it as dog whistle
they proceeded to basically scrutinize
everything that i've ever put up online
uh they went to my twitter they started
real
they're like oh he follows this that in
person jordan peterson ben shapiro
whatever i followed left-leaning people
as well
but they didn't care about that they
just said it's a dog whistle we
elected we we gave all these upvotes to
a guy who is
a crazy right-wing psycho whatever so
the next day
uh they basically downvoted everything i
posted
including um more comics it doesn't
matter
i tried to explain myself and i realized
on reddit you can't because if they
downvote you
no i'll see you they'll brigade you yeah
your answers are invisible basically
so basically long story short they ran
me off the website
so for a while like so so in the context
that we were just talking they assumed i
was a crypto
fash alt right i don't think dog
whistler i don't think that's true
i was in a high position i think it was
just crabs in a barrel
this guy's clowns also pull them back
down that's very likely as well because
you said that the previous guy was on
the throne they went after him
yes he i guess he did too good too
yeah they they wanted any time someone
does too well on the internet or
anywhere in society it's like hey let's
cut them down
just crabs yeah that may have been it
that may have been it and
they just want an excuse to chop people
like that down so
because i kind of called them out on it
i said this is what you're going to do i
had already drawn the strip of them
lighting me on fire
and then i put it up the next day like i
basically told you guys what you were
going to do and you did it
yep and then i reaped the fruits of that
and my career was ruined
i wouldn't say so well it's a weird
story of how i got to where i am now
but um no for for several months i
thought that was the end
and uh yeah i was like all right so then
you just went the other direction and
started drawing joe biden eating people
and you know well that was an accident
but
you accidentally drew joe by and eating
someone well that was what 18 months
later something like that so i had been
drawing comics
still on the side uh earning a few bucks
here and there
drawing indie comics basically i have a
series called mary sue that uh got
crowdfunded on
uh indiegogo it was pretty healthy i had
a little comic strip
that kind of got me through that year
some people were very kind to buy my
books
and i found a new home on twitter i
guess by accident i was drawing
political strips and they kept doing
better and better
um and then people kept just saying hey
your comic strips
are better than your indie comics so
keep drawing comic strips and i
i draw my though i think which was the
biggest
one because was it the the the biggest
one of the time for me
yeah i'll never vote for you and he says
then i'm afraid you ain't black he sucks
out the blackness out of the lady and
she falls over
and now she's right and then you did the
kanye west but he like reverses it
because he's got
dragon energy there's a whole series of
these
and um yeah they're it's just the silly
it's just dumb
i don't think my comics are better than
anyone else's but i guess it just tapped
into something and people responded to
it at the right place right time we were
talking about that earlier just drawing
joe biden with like
his eyes are black and he's drooling as
he raises his hand and says i'm afraid
you ain't black he's
he wants that energy i guess yeah it's
you know a political a good political
comic i think is timely i kind of
compare it to like a ripe fruit
it's only funny for a day or two and
then if i draw the comic too late it's
not even worth drawing because
i don't know what the joke is in this
one but i love it eating the
uh bernie girl yes it's bernie girl
what's your okay boomer or whatever her
name is
uh that series all right so it's it
sucks to explain a joke because
it's not funny anymore but the the joke
if you put it on ian you can see
this part yeah i did i should have found
it i drew that one after
uh he won what do you call it when it's
not super tuesday right right he was
he was chosen as the democratic guy
right yeah the nomination so
the punch line there is that he's
absorbing bernie support
oh right so all i know is you drew a
picture of bernie right
of biden with gigantic crooked teeth
eating
a young woman that's amazing and then
whatever that is in the bottom right
corner
first he smells her yeah of course
he unfortunately consolidated all of the
bernie supporters at the time they
didn't want
nobody wanted biden back then we got to
remember no nobody wants biden now
yeah no for real nobody does but all the
people voted for him are complaining
about him already they have to
get in line behind the champion to beat
the uh the reigning champion who they
hate the heel in this wrestling match is
trump and we have to
support anyway even if it's kamal harris
everyone knows it's going to be coming i
really can't stand this system
where we cult worship one person in the
middle and everyone like
circles around them humans and that's
that's that's that's another
simplification
uh the process started with a ton of
people
and there are a bunch of different
people supporting a bunch of different
people and then one by one you find the
one person everyone kind of
you want to put on the throne you kind
of well i mean we're talking about just
one of the
offices of the 50-something thousand we
have in this country so
i would be happy to have like a council
of people we do it's called the supreme
court no i mean
as president like 12 people to run as be
the president but so so the reason the
founding fathers created three branches
is because
they made literally what you're
describing so i would like now the
executive branch to expand and become 12
people
functioning as the president well the
common citizen i think
doesn't want to uh they don't want to
really run these high level
problems they you know they've got
enough problems on their own the family
work and stuff like that so
we have to choose people to make these
decisions for us hopefully they're
trustworthy
a lot of the times it turns out when
people climb to a certain level in
society it turns out they're almost all
corrupt for some reason that's a weird
pattern
um but we like to choose people to do
our thinking for us because
who has time to micromanage uh
international affairs
i'm not i don't have time to study that
the reason we have one
president is that this is a specific
branch designed for rapid response yeah
i get that
so it's like if if someone's like i'm
going to fire a missile at you and you
had three presidents they'd like what do
we do i say we do this no we do this
all the non-rapid response stuff he does
is a little excessive
maybe we could have a council for like
making policy or doing vetoes but that's
but that we do it's called congress veto
power
it's crazy that one guy can veto
something right you should have to have
a group of people
absolutely if
it's called congress then trump can veto
and then congress does
a two-thirds vote to override the veto
but i don't like yeah so you need a ton
of people to override the president
excellent
i think one you should have to have a
ton of people it's called checks and
balances and it's working
to override congress's motions too the
courts can overrule them too
but then at least checks and balances i
mean you would the supreme court maybe
it's brilliant you need a court of
people we don't have one supreme judge
no we don't know why we have one supreme
president it's a little dis
disgraceful it's designed no
disconcerting it's it's designed
very very well actually but it's
designed to run slowly is the problem
when you have a crisis you can't have
the slow-moving machine but that's why
you have a president
who can respond with war powers that's
the argument but that's literally why
they did it
they if when you have when you have a
direct democracy you get
tyranny of the majority and you get slow
response to a crisis
when you have a council of elders then
you know you have the
learned bunch but you still can't move
quickly now he's got the
supreme court nomination power that's a
little extreme for one person
but that should know a group of people
the issue you're mad about is the
democrats
when harry reid took away the two-thirds
requirement for for a supreme court
justice
confirmation blame them for it they
changed the rules
to manipulate the system to gain power
and it backfired on them i think
the auxiliary war powers that george
bush gave the president with the patriot
act success yeah well he didn't get with
the patriots congress did yeah
so the issue is ridiculous that one
person has that kind of power so the
problem isn't the one person it's the
legislative body that you are asking for
giving power
over and over and over again endlessly
and that's why the approval rating for
congress is like
20 or something why do we have i i think
it's both the problem is both i don't
like that there's like we
one person gets so much power the most
powerful person in the world
for four years and then then the next
person gets their
their their sloppy chops to go be the
most powerful person
nobody that didn't earn it they just got
voted in simplistic view
you could argue that like chuck grassley
or mitch mcconnell are more powerful no
the president can order a drone bomb
no he can't he needs approval of
congress to declare war well obviously
the problem is no
not declare war or issue a drone strike
he can't yes he's not supposed to be
able to do that i know
and congress had the power levy war and
granted ridiculous power to the
president
that's too much power yes absolutely but
trump has been curtailed every step of
the way through lawsuits over and over
and over again
almost everything he's tried to do he's
getting jammed up i don't have a list of
his executive orders i'd like to get a
list of
they wouldn't even they let obama create
daca and then when trump was like then
i'll and daca you can't do that
it was like well obamacare had too much
power too but so so so trump has less
power
good i'm glad he got scrutiny in the
exact in the office they went a little
nuts with it
but we the problem is over time the
rules kept getting changed to make it
easier for the ruling class
they wanted the rhinos and the dinos the
democrats the republicans their only
mission is
can i be popular more popular than the
other guy to get elected so i can get
the keys to castle then you get lindsey
graham this is a perfect example of this
lindsey graham says trump should fight
he needs to fight this and i'm going to
donate and i believe everyone should
fight
and then he goes into the senate floor
and he fist bumps kamala harris and pats
on the back and walks away
he has nowhere because he doesn't
actually care about trump fighting
for reelection he wants people to think
it so that they vote for him and they
did
and then secretly he's like you go
kamala congratulations
they don't actually care about you don't
like the system man they're getting
bribed no i don't like the people
but we got one of the best systems in
the world the problem is we've got a
bunch of bad people it's the worst form
of
of government except all the other ones
that have been right yes that's
that's the was it winston churchill
winston oh winston
and he's right it can be improved yeah
we're kind of
just you know spitting about how did how
we have the we have the process for
amendments the problem is
right now you've you've had over a long
period of time this war has been going
on this figurative war whatever you want
to call it the middle east stuff
no no no no the democrats like harry
reid in 2013 saying we're going to
change the rules that we can pass
whatever we want instead of compromising
with republicans oh god
and then and then mitch mcconnell said
bark by wards you will come to regret
this
and probably sooner than you realize and
then
now trump's got three supreme court
justices through because they
changed the rules because they were
power hungry and said
i could negotiate with you as we're
supposed to do
no we'll just all agree to change the
rules because we have the majority
and congress can vote to give themselves
raise oh
all in favor of giving us more money i
all opposed
motion passes they do it all the time
wonderful
i love it um i think we were talking
about this yesterday i said i think
we're on the brink of um
getting rid of that that group of people
that representation
style and just start having more of a
direct representation system
i don't know but i don't think we can
well because
it doesn't work you would have to start
a completely new country on some
continent that hasn't been discovered
yet i would think instead of like
voting for someone that makes all the
decisions in their own head
you could just vote for your segment of
the of the decision
but they but like to say they make all
the decisions it's ridiculously
simplistic but like okay 700
000 people vote for one person and then
that one person gets their say amongst
the other 230 or whatever
now what if instead the 700 000 people
got one 230th of this choice
yes or no and then every 700 000 people
gets 1 200. that's just called direct
democracy no it's a rep
it's a direct representation you don't
you cut out those people that can get
bribed
i think corruption is going to find its
way in no matter what we do the
the more uh checks and balances we have
in place the better but
unfortunately when you get enough
corrupt people into a system they're
going to invite their friends to be
a part of it hey let's also be on the
take and they have all the kinds of like
creepy
they get all kinds of i learned the word
compromat uh last year
oh yeah compromising material man they
even if you don't want to vote for
something it's like hey we have a
this uh video of you eating uh captain
crunch and everyone hates captain crunch
and
we don't want that to leak do we so you
gotta vote for you know tricks
and it's corruption is going to find its
way in no matter what i think
these systems have to be built with
human uh the
human capacity for uh corruption evil if
you want to use it that but
who gets to define what the word evil
even means um
the more the more i'm sorry i think the
issue is that
the only people who really want to be in
office are those who want power
and regular people who probably do a
better job of it don't want to bother
don't don't do it even a lot of people
who vote for a certain
if you have a vote maybe they get a
stack of paperwork like
this it's so thick and it's like who's
going to actually read through all that
rand paul rand paul i like him he's like
the only one that's
a guy who i really was a small back then
yeah it's um
but most of them it's just like oh let's
talk about what the summary is and i'll
just vote whatever they don't
that's the whole point of a republic
anyways like i'm gonna pick someone to
do all that reading for me so i can go
and live my life i think i think we're
starting to see this wave
i think both the left and the right has
a wave of new
up and coming politicians who believe
what they say
yeah and i might disagree with with some
of these lefties but i respect them more
than some of these fake plastic pieces
of the castle democrats or republicans
so on the right you've got uh who's that
who's that woman who just want uh one
she owns the restaurant she's the gun
lady oh her name is lauren bobert
colorado yeah right uh there's people
like her she really cares
she got politically active she ran she
won and you can see that someone like
her regular person who wants to do
something good at least
i that's that's that's the the
impression that i get compared to like
these stodgy suit wearing
plastic politicians that don't actually
care you then have people on the left
like nancy pelosi
she does not want to do anything for
anybody she's awful
but then you get some of these young
progressives who are running and they
really want to see
legitimate change and they're adamant
when they say green new deal in
medicare for all they really believe
it's the right thing and hey you know
what i might disagree with a lot of the
how they want to go about it with like
weird intersectionality stuff but i can
respect them way more they actually want
to do something because i think it'll
help people
i mean they say the path to hell is paid
with good intentions so you still have
to push back on bad arguments
there's a big difference between like
nadler and
like one of these upstart progressives
to be fair i wouldn't even put aoc in
that category because she's one of the
worst
aoc is the perfect representation of the
keys to the castle democrats
she goes on social media she finger
snaps and clap backs and
and that's her whole thing i get the
feeling that she's not speaking her own
words there's someone speaking through
her
well it used to be that way it was uh
was it cycad chakra barty and then he
resigned
or something right so who knows who's
speaking through her now but
i don't trust it's it's weird because
it's kind of like taking a youtuber and
giving them
political power it's like they're she's
an influencer more than
a because her district is like tiny
right i mean she's got 700 000 people
but it's
geographically small right but her
influence is uh monstrous throughout the
yeah throughout everywhere so she's more
of an influencer in terms of youtube
than uh she's a little district
this is this is what i'm worried about
in terms of how politics will happen in
the future
because she has so many followers she
can snap her fingers and raise an insane
amount of money
that's it that's maybe that's what they
were looking for there's some kind of
the internet age has spawned a new kind
of politician
star that that's a new and very scary
i mean we're at the whim of i mean you
want to talk about how scary trump is i
mean
he could say something at least he has a
counterbalancing force
whereas aoc she can say something
mobilize her whole
uh all of her people that are backing
her but
the biggest weapon that the right has is
calling her dumb and that's the
stupidest strategy you can
like you got the shapiro types and uh
crowder and all those people they're
calling her names and stuff it's like
bro
you're feeding her base you're making
her stronger by making fun of her
by calling her dumb and whatever you
have to take her very seriously
and i don't take so seriously because
it's silly but someone
but you know to be fair even if you may
have made a video or like if shapiro
and or crowder did and they and they
said nothing to insult her and just said
you know and ben was like i think aoc is
absolutely incorrect on this point and i
respect her her you know efforts to to
push for the green new deal but you
gotta recognize these things are wrong
all the left is gonna do is eat it up
and say he's talking about aoc and
they're gonna say really dumb things
like she's not gonna date you ben
oh my god well remember when he asked to
debate her she said are you cat calling
me
right give me a break but she she makes
her arguments on an emotional level so
right she it's like playing uh checkers
versus chess man like
people eat up what she says because they
humans are fundamentally emotional
creatures
the intellect is a thing that's like you
have to you have to a be educated to
even understand what
the rational people are saying you have
to be willing it takes effort it's like
a higher resolution
way of perceiving the world but the
lower resolution way the nintendo 8-bit
version
is the emotions appeal to the emotions
this person's bad this
is this is a scary thing there's people
suffering and the only way we can save
them is by doing this
and never mind that it's going to
bankrupt the country it's the right
thing to do because it makes me feel
better it makes me feel about trump no
just in general like say
universal basic income or something i i
disagree with that i think there's a
million bad
there's a million uh side effects that
we don't want to happen because of ubi
let's say
um it sounds good on paper there's
people
that can really do a lot with that money
it sounds like a seven-year-old's answer
to a problem
if people are hungry just give them
money cause then they can buy food well
that's a food stamp sar
so it's like yeah but but when we're
talking about
like covet lockdown especially the
government should just tell everyone to
stay home and not work and then give
everyone money because then they can use
the money to buy stuff
and then you say yes yes honey but then
if everyone's home who makes the stuff
you would buy
but like the food's at the store money
is a social construct
no but like i actually got an argument
with someone who said if we did a ubi
during like if we did like a ubi for the
lockdown then people would have money to
go to the store and buy stuff and i was
like and what would they buy
like what do you mean they'd buy food
and who would put the food there
what are you talking about like the
foods at the store and i'm like people
put it there
and then where does where does where do
the people get it from the guy in the
truck and where's the guy in the truck
get it from from the people who put it
in the bottles in the first place and if
you tell everybody to stay home
then you're not gonna have stuff to buy
it's really freaking scary dude it's
they want mommy and daddy back
it's yeah they're scared they are
de-aging
the whole country and we just want to
feel safe
and okay again they want us to be
dependent i'm trying not to use strong
language but like
they want us to be bottle drinking out
of the yeah
i i wanted to use another so i
absolutely have to clarify
i understand there are essential workers
because that's the first thing they
always say when they're like dude there
are essential workers who are doing
these jobs
it's kind of messed up they have to so
they should get a stimulus too and i'm
like
dude you can't have
every single job be essential the
bottling plant the dairy farm
the truckers the you know the
manufacturing for the bottles to bring
it there
the people working at the store because
otherwise you're just telling me that
everything's essential
i guess of course djs aren't or
something like that fine
so so but the problem is your money
becomes substantially worth
less and there's less to buy and the
other problem is that
because the supply chain got disrupted
in the initial lockdown
there wasn't any milk the dairy farmers
had nowhere to send the milk to because
the bottling plants had shut down
because they got infected with covid
and then they couldn't process the milk
they just dumped it on the ground and
then the farms and all the crops they're
like we can't get anybody to pick it up
or process it
so they just they tilled it back into
the land and just rolled it over
so these people don't understand the
economy
is okay it's it's a house of cards
almost i've
you know i know that's been used in a
negative way to mock the stock market
but it literally is like it's a very
very delicately balanced
supply chain for sure and if you take
one piece out of it other pieces start
to crumple and fall apart
and we saw that earlier in the year when
you couldn't like it was really
difficult to buy
basic things i remember because of the
supply chain disruption
you couldn't buy professional equipment
i was trying to get like a power cable
for a camera
gone all this is crazy this is only like
two months ago
all the all the video game consoles gone
from everywhere even still it's still
i hear it's just insane the most
essential isn't that crazy
i know you don't need these things but
it's like that who
why why why why can't we get a
playstation because people couldn't make
places because the supply chain broke
yeah i i ordered a bedroom set and they
were like it'll be there in february and
i was like are you serious i ordered it
in september
give me a break so what do you so so
they give you money what do you buy with
it
and so what's going to happen is the
money is i guess potentially like what
mass
deflation of some sort if there's
nothing to buy with the money the money
becomes worthless property values are
going to go down
because the only thing you can buy are
essential goods it's a perfect uh
perfect storm for a revolution i would
say people are depressed at home they
need
change they're broke they've lost
everything they're angry they need
someone to blame it on
and the rates are getting richer the
poor are getting poorer well no maybe we
should light some fires i don't know
what they're doing yeah stay warm
somehow
how do you feel about congressional term
limits uh that sounds great
we should do that especially if they
don't know how to send text messages on
their own phone or
set up their own email accounts or
something like that i think
if you're we live in the internet age
and the internet is a very scary thing
i think if you need to be able to vote
if you have the right to vote on it you
should be able to answer certain basic
questions
you know i think i've i've thought about
this the most perfect form of government
call it goblinism yeah where basically
you have one king
right and then in order to become king
you have to kill the king can i kill the
king then yeah anybody okay
anybody and then you're not gonna you're
not gonna come after me i mean someone
might oh
but so so i i forgot what it's actually
like where this is going
right ism registeredism where uh you
kill the king to become the king
despotism but think about it no no no no
no no better than that because anybody
can become the king
the issue is you have to really want to
be the king
right so that would deter people who
just wanted you know luxuries and coming
back
i don't want to live under the sword of
damocles if we were going to do turns
i'm kidding by the way i don't think
that would be that's just
okay good if we were gonna do term
limits um but congress wouldn't vote for
their own term limits can the citizenry
get like a 51 percent
demarchy what's that demarchy is like
you get congress duty in the mail
you'd like you'd go to your mailbox and
you'd be like oh
i got congress duty but but okay so
you're gonna go to dc we're gonna
install in congress
we're gonna institute it what is it like
um if we were gonna get the national
initiative
uh approved we'd have to get 51 percent
of the population to vote it and then we
could just bypass congress
if we wanted to do something as a
citizenry 350 million of us
if we got a hundred and ninety you would
need a constant you you'd need numerous
constitutional amendments
could we pass an amendment to the
constitution without congress if we as
citizens statewide 51 percent so so you
need congress
but the states would all pass it and
then once two-thirds ratify it
congress can but if whatever 170 million
of us decided we wanted something
couldn't we just buy i'm not a democracy
we are not a democracy but
but we are not a democracy and how can
we even verify those votes though
like open source to me blockchain but
people tell me no blockchain is not
there it doesn't verify anything dude
what do you understand
maybe uh a database guys
500 uh votes you'd be like the
blockchain says they're real
and the guy just forged them i mean we
could always vote on stone tablets
yeah absolutely can't mute those unless
you have a
i don't want to go backwards to handheld
votes that you got to give someone to
carry somewhere
can to someone to take to somebody else
that you hope they're doing right can
you secure
can you secure the database perfectly
and permanently i don't know
that's it i mean perfection no no one
can ever do anything
but you can secure a box perfectly and
permanently
perfectly for the most part for the most
part compared compared to a computer
system
i can take a lock box i can wrap it in
chains i can put it in a cement block
and no one's ever going to get inside of
it
they could steal it a gigantic five-ton
concrete block wrapped into the
government could steal that the point is
you you you say blockchain voting and
then eventually
and then and then google rolls out
quantum computing and they can unravel
they can unravel the blockchain and they
can change whatever they want without
you knowing
because google's already got quantum
computing capabilities so this
encryption could be compromised as far
as we know already i have a feeling that
the uh
the system they've been using what is it
called this stupid computer system
that's proprietary
yeah this dominion thing has already
been compromised it seems like well yeah
but so if you did blockchain voting
you're assuming that no one has the
capability to break the encryption
okay then if not blockchain voting
something like an immutable database of
some sort
like physical paper that three people
have to witness
but how would you get if if 170 of us
voted where would those three people
come from that that means
we've been we actually people we
actually used to do this everywhere in
canada they do it
that's what they do they have three
people while they're counting ballots
and they all scrutinize the number
and then they have so physically pull up
you draft people to be like vote
processors how do you think how do you
think we count ballots now
dude i have you put it in a machine no i
have no we have
a democrat a republican and a tabulator
and they sit at a table and they go
through it but then
they put it in the machine and the
machine things get mixed up i guess
so the issue now is like some memory
card think it uploaded after the machine
processed them or something so for the
most part
we we have we used to actually have
scrutinized
paper ballots and then we got we got
away from them and now we have
compromised technology
because a voting machine is less secure
than a hard piece of paper well you're
assuming that those paper votes were
accurate
i would be very surprised well we have
we have affidavits saying many of these
paper ballots look to be
like forged or fake and thinking in the
1800s i can only imagine the amount of
voter there was a bunch of like dude
before the internet
a guy could walk up to a voting booth
and wave a gun around and then people
would run away
and that's it and then what are they
going to do about it nothing today
tell no one it'll come after your family
yeah yeah that kind of stuff today
there's someone gonna be filming it
and they're gonna look what this guy's
doing i want like to be as least
associated with the process as possible
so like that's why i like internet
voting so you don't have to go to the
polling places because people are like
standing outside with baseball bats
i don't like that you should be able to
vote from the safety of your own home
there's always going to be some corrupt
way to get around it i'm sure
maybe i'm not seeking perfection i just
want to print the system
i i don't know okay there's other things
called like the dat protocol
um it's another decentralized service we
we could use some i'm sure we could
improve and create some sort of internet
service that we could vote on
be too easy to hack and then you'd get
foreign hackers foreign governments
would be like
let's do this we're doing that anyway
dude yes but there's a difference
between having a hard paper ballot that
can be pulled up and audited later
the problem is the democrats are
rejecting the audit if we audit these
papers and there are fraudulent machine
stamped
votes we're going to find them so it's a
shame that democrats are saying don't do
it because we need to
and they're not so they're not doing i
guess in georgia they weren't doing
signature variation verification to a
heavily scrutinized degree
and the other problem is this is what
the trump campaign brought up
same day registration basically voids
the need for a signature
because if you walk and say i'd like to
register and then you put mickey mouse
then you vote mickey mouse they're going
to compare it looks good to me
same day registration what if we did a
vote like we just did
but it would additionally put that data
on a blockchain
so it's like a third form of
verification somebody could then
break the encryption change it and then
sue saying look there's a discrepancy
and you'd be like well no i didn't vote
for that guy that the blockchain is
wrong and they're not going to ask 500
million people you would have to check
it on your own
it would just be another form of
security don't you get about
when someone steals a vote the person
doesn't know or care dude if you don't
check who you voted for then you're a no
no no no no
right now that's who you voted for ian
there are people
who were called by matt brainard from
the voter integrity fund
and they were asked if they voted and
they said no yeah that kind of stuff
guess what if you didn't vote why would
you check to see if you did
everyone should check to see if they got
voted for it they absolutely should but
why would a person
a regular person is going to be like i
don't know whatever because dominion
sketches it's not about dominion i'm
talking about it's about
somehow these people requested an
absentee ballot and then mailed it in
and then when they were asked they said
i didn't ask for a ballot yeah yeah we
should be protecting ourselves right now
i think it's it's your
civic duty i'm just yeah i think we
could test blockchain stuff by doing it
in addition too
i think saying blockchain has always and
consistently been a buzzword
and people haven't given any an actual
reason why we would why should we should
use it
it's just like blockchain technology man
it's like and and
it's not like an excel sheet when it
gets put on there it stays on there and
if it gets changed you see the change
so you're saying if we had a publicly
visible database with with active
archiving we wouldn't need blockchain
well if it was immutable yeah well it
could be mutable but people can watch
the changes happen in real time
well ideally it wouldn't be mutable if
it was a voting so
a voting database you just google's role
set in stone
stone google's got quantum computing and
they can probably unravel and break
dude nothing's perfect so then why we're
destined for corruption
so why not try why bother creating a
system that the average person can't
understand instead of creating something
rudimentary simple and easy to secure
like a piece of paper
it's not easy secure it absolutely is
dude
as we can see they're not doing it
because it's a
pain in the behind to count 350 million
votes
evidence exists and they're refusing
to properly go through it is a very
different problem to they didn't exist
i i just if you have i think if you was
extremely intelligent how you think that
paper
ballots is secure is insane to me it
it is one of the most insecure ways to
function i think you don't understand
how computers work that's why
then you're not using paper ballots if
you're using computers right no no no i
think so you don't understand how
computer security works like infosec
so like it's impossible to secure a
system period it's a fact of course
that's why cyber
cyber security is often focused on
offense as opposed to defense
because it's almost impossible the
amount of holes that exist in a system
to actually secure it
so you're basically saying we have paper
ballots which have security issues let's
create the most insecure system possible
to help
to use alongside it that doesn't make
sense i'm not saying replace it
you it is so easy to manipulate a
database database without anyone
noticing
but if you had a box of paper ballots
you gotta break into the warehouse
and then you have to pay someone to do
it for you yeah there's lots of ways to
get a box of paper dude
and if you've got three people who have
scrutinized the numbers and you have
sealed boxes stacked and buried
somewhere it's a lot harder to change
than just sitting in
your mom's basement with your gigantic
overweight belly you type in a computer
your 300 pound hacker like trump said
and then you go changed
make it hard i don't know enough about
it security is about making it harder to
do
right bribing a security guard to break
into the building committing various
felonies
and then stealing paper bouts which
three people have already certified the
number and the number changes they all
say
that wasn't the right number we all
agree okay we got a problem what
happened
check the security cameras hey look the
security guard broke somebody in
lock them up with a security system
they're gonna be like
they used a proxy with a yagi antenna
blasting two miles away to get wi-fi
from a starbucks
broken the guy was probably in russia we
have no idea where the attack came from
so check the paper ballots you can check
the paper ballots right now and if
i'm saying in addition to if something
goes wrong what's the point of the
blockchain at all
is it's a third form of security how is
it security at all because you can
verify if it
is exactly the same it's already it's
redundant it's of course it's redundant
we need redundancy to prove
to prove the system dude that's the
point if you've got multiple people who
have certified and you
you have the physical ballots and you
can count them right now then the
blockchain is just a waste of time no
it's a redundancy it's not a waste of
time what does it do
it triple checks the system why would
you need to if you've already had three
people check
dominion's proprietary or you could have
dudes urinating on paper ballots and
destroying them not
using dominion i'm talking about
regular people like they do in canada
watching the vote physically
physically be counted and all three of
them say we agree and then moving on
whereas in pennsylvania they pushed
everyone 30 feet away or 100 feet away
and put them behind a barricade
so they'd use binoculars that doesn't
make sense i know and they're still
saying that it's fine and good thing is
there are paper ballots
the problem is the security envelopes
were destroyed already so
there and therein lies the the main
problem first
we have the the voting machine is
irrelevant we need to check the actual
paper ballots now the good thing about
the dominion system is that they try and
manipulate it through dominion
and it doesn't match the paper ballots
then you can say hey wait a minute
someone did something
so that works but all that really
matters in the end from what i'm trying
to say is
can we verify the votes and can we go
back and check them if something changes
yes
paper ballots are secure way more secure
to have a physical object
like i'll i'll tell you this you can
lose a bitcoin so easily
like how many people have lost bitcoin
ridiculous amounts
there's a story of the guy who went to
the dumpster desperately trying to find
his laptop bitcoins are gone
there was somebody i knew who had a
locked usb stick and they forgot the
password and they're like i can't get in
and i got like three bitcoin they're
probably freaking out now
whereas you piece of gold you put in
your basement you're like oh yeah it's
in the closet
but if you had a piece of gold and a
piece of crypto that
was basically i don't know like um for
that gold there was a piece of crypto
that you had so as long as you had one
you have the other
that would be better like it represents
the goal a piece of crypto so you're
talking you sell the gold reserve
banking like
if you sell the gold to someone or give
it to someone you also give them that
crypto as like a receipt with it
so you have they have that actually they
have coins with the barcode that holds
the
and so we could do something like that
with voting i don't i don't see what the
point is
just this reduc a security redundancy
i guess it's a sticky situation you guys
i know sticky situation let's read super
chats
it is time for super chat danker supreme
oh if you haven't already smash the like
button and subscribe
smash the like button subscribe if only
we could have representatives that knew
what to do and share this video guys i'm
sorry french
no george hugo no i think maybe what we
need is a robot that just tells us how
to live our lives
or advises us no mandates yes the deep
mind
can we just make corn we should make
corn make corn
can you show everybody the spinning
plant yes you can thank you there he is
doesn't it look like very cinematic what
should we do why does it look so good
i don't know it looks prettier than i do
holy cow very cinematic
good cameras huh i love it let's read
super chats
danger supreme says crowder just
released a vid today about how 170
000 votes in detroit have no registered
voters to match with them
some districts have literally no voters
registered but thousands of votes
it's between 25 and 30 minutes in he
starts talking about it
we better get some i don't know
something's got to be done
jjp says arose for the beautiful lydia
also thank you
what are the future plans for this
podcast plans to expand with many
businesses being shut down
great commentators like you could hire
like me people who lost jobs from covent
um i mean the future plans for the show
is i do too much work already so sitting
down turning the cameras on and talking
about stuff is about
like perfect yeah but there are plans
for some kind of news venture
so long as people can work on their own
but uh we'll see when uh when cobit
first started
like when the when the lockdowns first
started revenue dropped dramatically
like 60 something percent
like across the board because most a lot
of the revenue on youtube and facebook
is from small businesses in nearby areas
and when they all stopped advertising
because they're gone revenue went
gone yup
scott turner says the magnet spinning is
actually terrible for the plant
let it spin too long and it will puke i
don't i'm not i'm not sure the succulent
can puke
i don't think you can dailon smythe says
this is for g prime85 seeing art that
goes against the left where a lot of
artists reside gives me hope keep it up
bud
thank you there you go man you know
what's funny i don't intentionally
like i i would have and will make fun of
pretty much anybody it's just i don't
see any jokes going
in the the opposite direction i see a
lot of people making fun of the right
and i i've always said i'm moderate i'm
pretty
center-ish i just want there to be
balance so it's like oh
i've made trump comics like trump
punchline comics where it's like a silly
you know he's getting into his robot
suit or something like that or
he makes a funny thing that was funny i
sell a t-shirt where he's making like
this
face and he's like bigly something like
that yeah yeah it's funny you know we're
it's just i i want there to be balance i
i wish i could make fun of the right as
much as the left but
i just don't see there's a massive
vacuum
right um and i it just doesn't feel the
left is like
donald trump's orange and has small
hands and they high five each other
that's not a joke right
it's just a tribal signifier yeah i mean
yeah and we all clap together
so making the making the comic you did
where there's a little tiny trump being
lowered into the mech suit
right and his arms are all tiny and he's
like looks all serious but he has no
neck yeah
but brilliant there's also something
more to it than that i think this is
just a little theory of mine i think he
has a tendency like deep in his
character
i think he wants i'm not going to say
like he's like a little person on the
inside but like
but no i think he has a thing in his
head where he wants everyone to like him
like he'll right he'll do anything and
the joke being that like he's just this
guy with a little ego maybe it's like he
gets into his big suit and he's like i'm
a big tough guy
maybe there's more to it subconsciously
of like he
i see him as the kind of guy who he
wants to be liked by everyone
uh it bothers him that he's not and he
wants to pretty much
he he will that's the kind of guy i
would want as a president is a guy who
will
earn my vote i i feel like he'll work
extra hard to make me like him
he did he he did right off the left at a
certain point but if they if they
if they just praised him and and kissed
up to him a little bit he would have
given him
he banned bump stocks and the right got
furious but he was like the left is
being nice to me so i'll work with him
he's the kind of person i think that
just he lives for it he wants people to
hate him and then he converts them and
it's like
nectar to him the more angry people are
angry at him and then he flips them to
like him it's like this is the juice
like maybe
if you were a little kid and you were
bullied and then
i mean in a silly way let's put it like
this people gave me a hard time as a
cartoonist right
but now i'm here sitting and talking to
all these people
for me it's like this feeling of like oh
i told you so you jerks you were mean to
me and now look where i am
proven it right so maybe for him it's
the same thing like he
he wants he doesn't want people to hate
him but if he can just
flip them right so it seems that
psychologically he's got that thing in
his head where he wants to work hard for
that's the kind of guy i want uh leading
something let's
play i just feel like that would make
for a better leader than a guy that'll
just like do as he's told
yeah i don't know kenneth peterson says
hear me out lol trump versus biden in a
ring winner takes all joe rogan referees
come on but we know trump would win
like no joke yeah i don't know but what
if they pulled out their true forms
yeah so you got trump in his robot suit
and then monster biden monster fighting
who wins i don't know failsand says have
you looked into
the the ash conformity experiment i
think this is the method that the media
is using to get people to give in and
fall in line i look it up
patrick winter says they should hand
recount the whole country and see where
biden really stands yes
if you want trump if you want trump to
lose you want
you want that recount right because
trump's stealing the election
that's right that's right peter parker
says did you see how happy the reporters
were
to talk to president-elect biden today
saying things like it's an honor to
speak with you today
they all they they almost were bowing to
him
yeah yep dj white says what if all of
this is just one big make a wish request
for joe biden
everyone knows how long he has wanted to
be president and we all know he is on
his way off this rock sooner rather than
later
no because hillary would have been
elected what if 2016 was her like
you know her make-a-wish and they tried
huh it was so obvious that the weirdest
thing about the hillary election
was that the democratic primary was
nothing it was no one
it was like martin o'malley who was the
other guy lincoln chaffee was that who
it was back then i don't remember
2016. yeah she had like no one running
against in the democratic primary it was
weird
there was like no one who could really
but
it was obvious she was going to be the
only one up there and they were going to
prop her up
and then bernie came along and well they
didn't like that very much oh my
goodness bernie
gerald herbert says new suits in georgia
to delay certification
still not written in stone for joe they
are delaying for uh dominion
which could seal the deal for 45th if
trump
freezes three states with an injunction
he wins it's over
that's it he doesn't need to win the
states he just needs to stop them from
certifying so that joe biden doesn't
have 270
and then the house delegations vote for
trump that's it
it's actually not that far-fetched it's
just an issue of will the supreme court
intervene
if the state courts and the lower courts
don't
let's see asperger's adulthood says with
two presidents the cry of not my
president would have a lot more meaning
yeah that's true
reagan lodge says shout out to george
alphabetopolis
there you go what's up reagan it's
yeah it's uh i've been called every name
in the book galapagos
galapagos applesauce it's texas right
it's just greek i'm sorry it's just
greek yeah just plain old greek and
actually as far as greek names go it's
very mild
yeah it is it's only five syllables
right
yeah five that's very easy xd
interactive says that is how
they are going to attack the tenth
amendment first that gives them the
power to go after the rest nationwide
what's the tenth amendment uh that power
is not granted the federal government or
reserve for the states
something like that right yes yeah that
sounds nice my favorite yep
jay everett says they called georgia for
biden again
117 says hey tim do you think elections
should be staff guarded and maintained
by the national guard as opposed to
volunteers
i mean they literally do almost nothing
all month
maybe i don't know rudy rabbit says this
one's for ian keep doing you bud i like
you
thank you corey blair says tim right now
look up executive order one three eight
four eight
this is about foreign interference
interference in u.s elections
dominion in canada societal is in spain
ovum funds cital the eo is huge the
crack and possibly
segment on this eo asap yeah there's not
a whole lot there that a lot of people
keep bringing up this executive order
that trump has over foreign election
interference and then they make
reference to like oh but dominion is
based in canada
it's like theoretically trump could try
and enact some
crazy move using the it allows them to
sanction people
basically allows them to issue sanctions
for people who interfere in elections so
i really don't
see like i don't know i read through it
and i just didn't understand what the
hubbub was
gen z says governor wolf making ammo
illegal and making civilian police wait
what
look up pennsylvania hb2957
louis shanker says hey tim i'm a big fan
of your work i just launched a new 501c4
the academic accountability institute to
allow every student nationwide to
anonymously
restream their online classes to a
decentralized blockchain supported video
hosting site game changer
interesting that sounds awesome eve
welcome says will of the people is
inspirational
makes me want to learn guitar the media
really are the high priest of wokism
everything is clear now if you haven't
already check out my
original music video and song will of
the people it's more like a short film
it tells a story you should really check
it out it's on this channel but you can
just search youtube for
will of the people tim cast and uh and
give it a listen it's about four minutes
if you had some advice for them to learn
guitar what chords would you suggest
they
practice um like the easiest chords
probably like e
minor and a just two fingers you know
super easy yeah i like d c g those are
my first three
minor eight is really good but yeah e e
e minor and a are just your two fingers
so it's like
alice is built up you got anything yeah
my advice for anyone who wants to learn
guitar is think about the songs you want
to learn how to play and then
learn how to play them i guess i was
lucky though because i learned how to
read
uh tap i learned how to read music when
i was really little and then i just
totally forgot because i didn't care
and then i learned how to read tabs
because tabs were super easy and
simplified
ways of reading guitar music you know
yeah
omg jimmyboy says finally something ian
and i agree with
not concerned give this to ian tim he
deserves it give me
all right what'd you agree with me with
though the whole conversation about i
guess
redundancy i think you're a little kind
of right about that
mark conway says love what you're doing
always great to see chicago and do well
i think the elected officials are
overestimating people following these
lockdowns
several restaurants in my area are
staying open and local law has stated
they are not going to stop them
yeah that's that's a big thing i think
we might see open defiance
serious open defiance work or already
kind of seeing that in orange county
that's something that i saw actually
during the show orange county sheriff is
like we're not really going to enforce
this stuff we have other more important
stuff to look at but that's that is law
enforcement
but i think like regular people are
going to be like yeah for sure just
thanksgiving is going to do it spirit of
our nation uh
civil disobedience yeah man we don't
like being told what to do
i think that's the most american and
healthy thing that we could do as a
people
yep without violence yeah i do not
support that at all
theft don't do it it makes you look
stupid and wrong and it only undermines
your position
exactly interesting uh
there's no name on this it's just an m
tim have you seen matt brainerd's
interview with jack murphy matt
identified over 20 000 people in georgia
who no longer meet residency
requirements to be able to vote
wow troy bruce references
the uh the votes from stephen crowder
again so that's definitely disconcerting
to say the least
corey's story says lydia thank you for
introducing me to akira the don
meaning wave has been an amazing remedy
for this year and i can feel it actively
reprogramming myself for the better
please have him on wonderful i would
love to we will we will uh sort through
that
sean brown says have y'all seen the
video what are white people more
superior at
it's still up and is very racist you all
should check it out it got
ratioed michael conaway says reddit
kills free speech the tyranny of the
majority
yup yeah those down votes that's kind of
english
shooter 13 says i am so sick of people
suggesting changes to our government who
don't understand
its function to begin with oh i wonder
if he's talking about me
probably just kidding he probably is
barbie says i think the house
and senate should be like jury duty you
go you serve you get five dollars a day
you go home
you can't make it a career tim you're
awesome thanks for keeping it real
that's called demarcy
denmark is government at random so
basically when everyone turns 18 and
they get their driver's license they
also sign up for
civic duty which could be jury duty or
administer or legislative duty
and then one day you get letter in the
mail and it's like i got congress duty
it's like okay so for the next you know
three months
i gotta go down to dc and we're gonna
review bills and the
i don't know i don't know if it was
actually a good idea but the general
ideas behind it are that
because you have limited power you gain
nothing from it
people are scared to like openly defy
their fellow neighbors because they know
they're going to be out right away with
nothing
and so it's basically if i go in and
then some lobbyist tries to give me a
kickback or whatever
people are gonna know because i'm just
some dude who like works at a local cafe
if i start driving around you know a
brand new sports car people are gonna be
like yo what's up
so it's like you go back to your regular
life so soon you don't have millions of
dollars you don't have influence
there's no influence peddling there's no
fundraising none of that it's quite
literally
you're walking your dog one day you're a
dog groomer for your job and then you're
gonna notice that you're now
the senator for the next three months
and you could pay like a hundred
thousand dollars
a salary over three months like you
could pay them well to do that
so i think i think you yeah comparable
to the salaries they have now but for
three month period so you'd be like
some people might be like yes yeah
you're gonna get some good cash
for a couple months covid stuff like
this w but because there's no influence
peddling
beforehand to get in like you've got
people who are being lobbied and they're
like we're gonna we're gonna fund this
pack to help you get reelected but we
want to see favors you wouldn't have
that none of that
because they wouldn't know who's about
to become who's coming in to get sworn
in
you would just get your notification and
there would be even a selection pool
probably
where you get a notification saying you
got to serve in congress but before you
do they ask you like certain questions
and screen you and then like there could
be
lawyers from each party or whatever
challenging whether or not you can
actually be on congress
and then you might say something like i
disagree with that law and i'm like okay
well when we move to disqualify this
person
and then there would be a judge that'd
be cool like the supreme court could get
involved
i i just a federal court probably but uh
yeah maybe because it would be in like
it's a dc thing
i don't know if denmark actually would
work very well there's probably a whole
bunch of problems with it you know what
i mean
so whatever well states were a great
petri dish to see if these
ideas work out if some states implement
it and it works well maybe other states
can do it and then
it can butterfly flag i mean i love the
idea of states experimenting with
certain things like even
uh new jersey just passed uh the
marijuana thing it's or ranked choice
voting
i mean like maine and alaska i think let
them experiment that's fine i love the
idea of different states trying
different things and if you like the way
a certain state
governs itself you can move there and
it's like i'm among my people i feel
like i'm among my people i love that
idea that's
i don't like the idea of the federal
government being so strong that it's
affecting all the states all the time
just
let these micro cultures work and then
you can go live wherever you feel like
you're the most
most at home i love that idea uh i i
don't like the idea of uh
maybe we shouldn't make these like big
changes that affect all 50 states
all at once like let the states decide
more i love that idea
very conservative jonathan hall says
humans are flawed in everything we do
everything we make there is always flaws
but i believe our current system is
is the better in regard to taking that
into into account and before someone
says
then we make an uh ai a humans made it
lewis t says crowder read verbatim her
green new deal and that video was banned
wow that's amazing
super chat jump thanks youtube i love it
when they do that oh all over the place
sharon and hill tim i'm a long time
viewer and subscriber of your channel
keep it the great work thank you very
much sharon i appreciate it
paul mcgrath says new title the last
great american talk show is that is that
it i don't know
this show is like people talking about
stuff and that's about it
i try to be as crazy as possible
yeah i think it's i think it's funny
that like there's an assumption that
when ian and i have like an argument
like it's like that's that's kind of the
point you know what i mean like
in somebody you can't leave the room
it's true when you're having dinner
she'd be like
these guys no but like uh how dumb would
the show be if it was constantly
like just you were just like you're
right tim about everything you say and
i'm not gonna argue with you at any
capacity i got so
i want to hear more about you george i
got so passionate i want to hear a
little bit more about your story
yeah um i know we're in the middle of
super chat talking sounds great
as opposed to throwing fists i love that
idea we should
explore that more oh did you actually
mean that you want me to talk more yeah
like what's your middle name
i don't have one really really nice is
that a greek thing uh
you know i don't know do you enjoy grape
leaves
uh no i don't i love those things it's
like 20 questions
um do i like souvlaki yes yeah yeah
what's your favorite greek food
uh uh uh i can't answer that because
that's too controversial in my people oh
awesome
there was a yes mike cernovich likes to
tweet ask me anything
and so i saw that once and i tweeted i'm
having water pressure issues in my
bathroom
one day you know just earlier it was
working fairly well but now i turn it on
it kind of comes out a trickle is there
a way i can remedy this
and then i actually got a ton of
responses from other people yeah and
they were right they were like take off
the aerator and you'll probably find a
jam and i was like oh wow there was
stuff jammed in there look at that it's
crazy
but uh mike didn't give me a good answer
boo but he said ask anything
you know and so i did i was like i gotta
fix the water pressure from the bathroom
sink man
jerk tied out right now he tried he he
he he said he suggested drano or
something but i guess he didn't
understand it was coming from the faucet
not in the drain
but it was it was it turned out we
actually had a uh the water softener
filter broke and so these little
water softener beads were spraying
everything was awful the worst thing
ever way to get the whole system purged
horrible jeez anyway
george yes sir tell me about your
website uh my website has been abandoned
for a long time
i don't maintain it i actually am the
most active on like twitter and
instagram these days and i have a little
youtube channel uh that's pretty much
where i
spend all my time these days where can i
buy your t-shirts uh
etsy i have a shop etsy.com
studio nj all the links are in my uh
twitter bio
oh right or my pinned tweet i should say
yeah hershey schwartz says you should
have invited harold heshee
tischel he is a gentleman that got
arrested after they protested the
lockdowns
that you can get a little bit more about
what's going on in brooklyn in the
jewish community dude that would be
awesome somebody would love to have him
to me yeah it might be the same person
how to reach out to that guy
so basically the hasidic community is
being targeted by cuomo
you know with these lock downs it's nuts
there's videos of a cop like
hole turning his camera on his phone and
then like recording
like to see through a window to like
make sure they're not secretly
practicing their religion
that's crazy dude yeah these this isn't
new york has gone nuts cuomo is crazy
man
anton maxson says battling to the death
for president sounds like the
necromonger way
from chronicles of riddick oh and by the
way in regards to ian's executive order
list comment
trump signed one into law november 17th
relation to hunter's laptop idk worth a
read
interesting thank you aldo pineda says
you should make an alex jones comic for
those walls
you know i was going to have back when
chaz was a thing
uh the only way the government can fight
chaz is to airdrop
alex jones in like a capsule he comes
down and he's just
ah he starts like hulking through the
streets something like that that'd be
amazing i like the one you have where
they're trying to guillotine
the trump effigy then it bites the
guillotine and then goes crazy and then
like they all run screaming i love silly
stupid crap like that you know they got
mad at me they're like oh he's uh
dog whistling support for trump dude
a trump puppet they actually did that to
a trump puppet and i thought it'd be
funny if it came to life and bit the
guillotine and came to life
fire fireworks were coming out of its
hands and it said trump 2020 because
that's what they had they had the
fireworks joe biden firing lightning and
vaporizing his audience it's fantastic
it's one of the best
and all right i was firing forced
lightning from his hands
i had i had a little note here i think
just
for the sake for posterity let me just
say like the humor
thing humor is such a beautiful
panacea to like our problems right now
everyone's taking things too seriously
can i just draw something silly and we
can just have a laugh
at our leaders oh this leader's done
this leader's dumb let's just
have a little pressure release and i
feel like
so there's a lot of like dark stuff
going on in our heads and like maybe
i was thinking that pressure the
pressure release valve
is in the darkest place that you want to
go into it's like people are scared to
go into the depths of their own mind
but it's like they're afraid to even
learn about themselves so
i think what i'm trying to say i guess
is
have more uh mercy on comics creators
my question is what horrifying and
traumatic experience
much must you have uh uh gone through to
draw a picture of joe biden
with a shocked little girl and his giant
monstrous mouth
consuming her like what why what
happened when i was
a kid i read these books called scary
stories to tell them
absolutely but you know i was telling a
lydia about this earlier there's this
artist named
something uh he's polish buckinski he
drew
the most horrifying images of like a
hellscape post-world war ii
uh i'm first i just i love dark drawings
like that but like this is
silly cartoons this is nothing but like
being able
i feel like somewhere in the human brain
there's like some connection between
horror and comedy like there's some
elevated like spike of emotion where i
want to cry and laugh and be scared at
the same time like
i'll watch a scary movie boo and then
i'll laugh afterwards horror movies are
funny
they can be fun there's something
communal about like the catharsis of
laughing at something horrifying so
maybe there's something to this i you
know i'm not like a crazy psychologist
or anything but
drawing a spooky comic worth monsters i
guess some people say like what i drew
recently
uh who's lightfoot coming out laurie
life would coming out of a turkey coming
out of a turkey and
and telling the pilgrims hey you're all
under arrest
and it was extremely disturbing i guess
for some people
but it's like it's so absurd i was
actually on the floor crying laughing
when i saw
my own drawing i'm like i can't believe
this came out of my hand
i can't believe i drew this but that's
what i felt so
relieved afterwards i was able to laugh
at something that's actually horrific
the authoritarian of like oh you can't
have family over
for thanksgiving that's sad but yeah i
was able to laugh at how ridiculous it
would be it's like a monty python sketch
really yeah
it's something they would have done
they're all under arrest it's it's dumb
it's funny let's have a laugh and feel
good about something that's actually
pretty dark i feel like comics
and comedy in general that fills this
gap that
people don't want to be upset and angry
and in pain all the time
comics maybe are part of the pressure
release algorithm
i don't it helps i i think maybe that's
why the comics are popular i don't think
they're anything special but maybe it's
just
it's good medicine for some people i
guess i i wish there was more of it
yeah humor and humor sure have the same
root right hum i mean it is what we are
if we had not been able to have humor
what else would we look at what happened
with stand-up comedians they weren't
able to even go on college campuses
a couple years ago they were scared of
being canceled
and they couldn't even tell certain
jokes because the the college students
were all like
oh you can't say a joke about that
that's too serious or that's too dark
that's the point of comedy you're
supposed to go into these dark places
and find something funny about it so
that we can have
a pressure release a little bit yes this
is something that paramedics
and nurses and doctors talk a lot about
soldiers a lot too
they find dark humor right incredibly
dark places and people think that
they're kind of crazy but you have to
laugh or you will cry and you'll be
useless
yes we got a super chat from jimmy
rustler he says tim it's not the right
that will be calling for the police
right or wrong a 17 year old kid with
one rifle and no reload survived a mob
what happens when the left meets 20 of
them when they hit him in their own
suburbs
the right seems to think that if it
comes to an actual civil war they'll win
and they don't realize they will lose
instantly
the right will lose any civil war
immediately
i'm exaggerating a little bit but uh
what will happen is in the event
there's any kind of coup or you know
trump
might win or whatever the internet's
going to go down
youtube facebook twitter are going to be
like we're shutting things down for this
or that reason
remember when twitter locked all the
accounts of verified users only verified
users
it's going to be something like that
like oh no some attack is happening
quick turn on cnn communication lines
will go down
and the only opportunity for regular
people is going to be there like alerts
or it's going to be
cnn i will say however to counter that
donald trump created the presidential
alert system remember that
yeah yeah so trump can like literally
text every phone in the country so
i don't know why but he made sure he had
the ability to have a direct line of
communication to the people
that had a bad idea so when when i say
that you know the right would lose
instantly i'm obviously exaggerating the
point i'm trying to make is don't
underestimate the left's control of
technological institutions
yeah google were gonna say something
george i know i was just gonna say even
if you quote unquote win
you may lose in the long run um i mean
if a civil war actually started everyone
loses period yeah there's no
there's no coming out of any kind of
actual violent conflict up
well that's not true the oligarchs if
you're if you're like a dirt poor person
and then everything falls apart and you
grab
your posse and you go take over
buildings that's what they did you know
post-soviet countries
so yeah there's that i guess i would
imagine that wouldn't be
sustainable though i agree with you i
don't think anyone would win not not
like the
regular citizens not us not it's like
people i know
it's like i notice a lot of people are
scared of what's going to happen but i
sometimes wonder if if they're more
scared of
who they are going to realize that they
are like let's say someone breaks into
your house and then you have to fight
them off
and then you realize like oh shoot i
have this dark
impulse in me that wants to hurt someone
it's really scary to realize that
you are this animal that can do really
dark things
like what happens in a case of a civil
war like do i go into the streets and
like hide in bushes and attack people i
don't want to do that
but people don't realize man what it's
like to be in a conflict like when
there's actual war going around like
if growing up in a city with high crime
you know people who grew up in baltimore
st louis or south chicago probably have
a better understanding than the majority
of people in this country
especially these progressive lefties who
come from like well-to-do families
they think they want a revolution man if
a revolution actually started or they
actually were standing
in in egypt when the revolution was
going on they'd be steamrolled
they would be crying they'd be curled up
in the fetal position crying i'd watch a
lot of
videos of vietnam veterans giving like
talking for an hour about their
experience in the jungle sometimes it
gets really really horrible
and they were young too yeah a lot of
them and the navy corpsmen that saved
like
dude there'd be six of them walking in
the line and the first guy always goes
down immediately when the gunfire
starts people running out first purge
and like it's chaotic and it happens in
like 20 seconds and then it's done and
like
you're lucky if you still have your leg
these people don't get it man like it's
it's funny when there was a there was a
video coming out of portland
where somebody got hit in the leg with a
rubber bullet and they started bleeding
it's like a light abrasion
and then the the larping medics were
like we need a tourniquet and they
literally put a tourniquet on this
dude's leg and he's like no i don't i
don't want to lose my leg and look we
got to stop the bleeding man i'm like
the dude got an abrasion from a rubber
it's like wipe it off so it's like dude
i've been skating and i've whacked my
shin like doing a tray flip and blood
just pours out for an hour
like i was skating with adam and he hit
his ankle and his his whole
sock was soaked he just kept skating
yeah and he's like yeah i just hit it
bleets but like then you have some dude
it gets like a light
bleed and they they put a tourniquet on
it these people
are playing a game they do not
understand and the only reason they keep
coming out is the cops are playing with
with kitty with kid gloves
if the cops actually went out and wanted
to hurt people they would they don't
they don't want to hurt people and so
because of that you get these people
look at the rubber bull and they laugh
about it it's fun and they come out
again and they keep doing it
they want to pretend like they
contributed like in the 60s you had the
hippie movements
we changed the world hey guys i'm going
to tell my grandchildren about the time
where i was in the middle of a riot and
uh i got hit with a rubber bullet and i
was bleeding that one time that was
crazy i changed the world that day
they want they want to feel like they're
a part of something they're bored
i hate you can look at the demographics
of what makes up a riot
group there's actual ideologues there
are people who are just bored and want
to feel like they're part of something
then you get the real psychos who just
want to do some crime and
blend back into the group anonymously
there's all kinds of this weird makeup
of like
all kinds of people who just want to be
part of the action
and when you get a mob of people they
say a mob of people's like the
intelligence is like a two-year-old they
one person says let's go this way the
whole crowd follows them like wonderful
101. yeah they just
this is a this is something i talk about
when it comes to marches street marches
and protests
in new york city it's anybody who wants
to can change the direction of the crowd
so this has happened a lot where there
was a protest against police brutality
and the occupy wall street people showed
up
and all you have to do is walk in front
of the crowd and turn and it happens
they see you turn and they follow you
and also the whole crowd just turns
it's an organism man yep it's it's
really scary i call it the grand falloon
it's it's like a a a mass of flesh
that's just
moving and rolling like a katamari i'm
talking in game turns i love that game
it's just yeah it's a role of people
that are just like following hey
let's go find some action over here
they're not thinking critically they're
not able to think critically they don't
and what's scariest is they won't listen
to reason they can't
they're just thinking as an organism
there's something weird in the human
mind
that like once they start linking up
networking
thinking as like one organism the human
mind it's like
it's really creepy and gross and scary
you can't reason with them i'm sorry
the only way out of that situation is
not to be there in the first place
reuben cruz says george did you go to
east lee county ohio
east lee can i don't know what that is
unfortunately so then you did not
no i'm sorry so a lot of people are
bringing up the crowder thing again so
you guys should check out what crowder
was talking about apparently votes with
no registered voters interesting
ross bremer says article 5 convention of
the states to get term limits is in
place mark levine wrote a book on it
interesting lka
says tim i disagree because people on
the right and preppers know how to use
ham radio
that's true oh yeah i was exaggerating i
was just trying to like make
i was trying to you know kind of just
like shock the people on the right to be
like listen
i'm going to say something but you know
because i often hear tweets and and see
post where they're like very sure of
themselves
never underestimate your opponents we
don't want war we don't want conflict
none of that should happen and hopefully
it's all just big talk and in the end
everything just simmers down but i gotta
say man
it's like earlier you know two or three
years ago when i was reading these
articles from like the atlantic that
said civil war was coming like no no
joke
like it was it was i think it was the
atlantic talked about the potential for
civil war saying it was really high
probability security uh um consultants
were talking about what they were saying
in the u.s with the street with street
violence
and then everyone said tim was crazy to
talk about it we're literally at a point
right now where president
president trump is refusing to concede
going through legal challenges but the
media is bypassing the constitutional
process to declare joe biden the winner
we are primed for the perfect
like this you could not have a more
perfect scenario to ignite a civil war
no joke two pres two people declaring
themselves the president yeah
and then and then not only that but you
had the war games from the democrats
where john podesta said
it is better for joe biden to have the
west coast secede from the union than to
concede to trump
so it's like all of these weird things
have lined up and it's worse than it's
ever been
so i'm not saying it's going to happen i
don't know i'm not a psychic
but like how do you ignore all of these
different things and then be like
nothing's happening nothing's going on
i fear that the only way to really
because
let's say there's a civil war that
happens in the way that you're
describing it would be
little cells and pockets scattered
throughout the whole country
and the only counter to that is
increased
surveillance which frightens me even
more
than open civil war when we talk about
like patriot act stuff like that
illegal search and seizure the only way
to really know
intelligence intelligence-wise what
these groups are going to be doing is to
spy on everybody
all the time um there's again the chess
game
we're way too far into this chess game
where there's no way out of this
everybody should they're not going to
cool off
it's not going to happen i don't know
what's going to happen i got a feeling
that
people love trump and they they don't
hate biden so if biden wins the people
that support trump aren't going to like
go against him
whereas the people that are on biden's
side hate trump
trump wins they would go crazy yeah so i
think if biden wins which it seems like
is going to happen
the people are just going to suck it up
and yep yep
conservative is going to be like ah put
the country first yeah but
like joe biden his hit osterholm is
saying national lockdown and biden's
like well i'll do the scientists say
it's like okay well then you know that's
that's that's that's it who knows what
kind of stuff he'll do behind the scenes
and
well he's gonna enrich himself and his
family well i mean what kind of uh
fortifications will they do behind the
scenes that we won't know about
yeah until oh yeah until they get
challenged again like all the
crazy voting stuff we never heard of
dominion before this
year you know i'm sure they've been
planning stuff like this for years
yeah as uh and and if you look at a lot
of the accusations
about like evidence to suggest that
trump or that biden cheat or whatever
notably like uh the bellwether towns
that you know 99 of the time whenever
they vote for a president the president
wins
this time it's like they it was like 82
failure rate
so whereas like for for 100 years it's
like their success rate was like 90 to
100
but this time it was 18 success and
everyone's like that doesn't make sense
like how does anomaly like that happen
and there's some people who just will
see that and they'll say i refuse to
believe that there's an explanation for
that outside of cheating
you know well don't jump to conclusions
no i think for sure but that is
definitely weird but there's a lot of
weird things and so my issue is
when you have these sworn affidavits
saying there's fraud literally outright
saying it like in georgia we do now have
five
when you have these brainerd anomalies
it's like uh dude we have widespread
irregularity
i'm not gonna say fraud because you have
to prove someone intentionally did a
thing
but something's not right no and the
democrats are saying don't look behind
the curtain i'm like
i don't trust anyone who says don't look
over here don't ask questions
that's the most suspicious thing in the
world to me is when you tell me i'm not
allowed
don't look behind that curtain over
there oh what's behind that curtain that
you don't want me to see
my dog is missing do you know where he
is no ruff ruff i just heard a bark
from behind that curtain don't look over
there you heard no i'm hearing barking
there's no evidence of it
there's no there's no widespread
evidence of missing dog
oh my goodness yeah they use the
canadian proprietary computer
software yep so weird canadians
yeah of course i love canada but it's
not an american product
and they don't use it in canada in
canada they do paper ballots
no yeah how about that well anyway
george
yes thank you so much for hanging out
hey man it's one of the greatest honors
of my life to be here thank you oh dude
we got your
all over the walls in this place it's
downstairs and upstairs real surreal
you drew hilarious comics and pictures
man crazy it's great joe biden eating
kids
there's like several of them i i
actually draw more stuff than that
these are great stuff the hillary
clinton face with like the weird bug
eyes
please look at my other stuff too guys
as well i'm not actually a disturbed
person
we have a lot of room for art on the
walls in this building uh
yeah man i'd be honored any time oh yeah
those that was one that i really wanted
was uh basically
what i i if you could do it at some
point maybe not but my idea was
um uh brian stelter and he's like got
like an apron on and a broom and he's
trying to clean
but he's all frustrated and frazzled
because there's little tiny like gnomish
vladimir putin's
like like running around causing
mischief and like knocking over a vase
and he's like
he's everywhere little putin's i want to
mural the skatepark
if you ever want to be involved with
something like that that'd be awesome um
that's that's that's that's what i want
that's like hard physical painting for
like a long time
like my sistine chapel just get a bunch
of painters from around the world to
come help us
yeah like a giant a giant monster joe
biden like this like looming down at you
oh my gosh
how about uh no i don't want joe biden
what do they do are they called decals
where you uh
paint a thing and print it and put them
in a ceiling board yeah
uh i don't like banksy style i don't
know like on the bottom of the
skateboard
there's a design yeah it's like a detail
i don't know anything about
skateboarding yeah yeah well so it's
they they they silk screen skateboards
they're yeah
something like that i mean probably
bigger companies do something different
but yeah you just like
i'll add that to my etsy story right on
well
ladies and gentlemen you can if you
haven't already smash the like button
and subscribe hit the notification bell
we are live monday to friday at 8 pm
uh and you can follow me on twitter
instagram parlor at tim cast
check out my other channels
youtube.comtymcastnyoutube.comtimcatsnews
where i put up videos all throughout the
day
uh george you are uh at g prime85
instagram twitter and uh i have a little
youtube channel where i interview comics
people uh which is just my name george
alexapolis you could look that up
cool yeah and then there's this guy over
here hi everyone i'm ian crossland you
follow me pretty much on all the social
networks and um share this
share this content with your friends if
you like what we do yeah tell them we're
the best
what did someone say the last great
american talk show yeah that's right i
like that yeah well we definitely want
to have more people on to talk about
crazier stuff
too because like what people don't
realize politics was not
like we were talking about sonic the
hedgehog and a bunch of other stuff
earlier
but politics dominated because this
election's been crazy and then maybe
this will become like the civil war
dispatch
i'm half kidding by the way only half
which is scary right but uh
yeah hopefully we can bring in you know
what i really want to bring in so i'm
going to talk about dmt
i know it's so cliches it's got to be
joe it's everywhere uh no but like an
actual researcher but also an expert on
like um near death experiences yeah
we've been trying to it's really hard to
get
like legit academics because they're
like i'm not a public figure and i don't
want to go on someone's show
so actually getting those people is
rough but it'd be so cool to have like
you know that kind of
that kind of conversation that story
freaked me out with the people in
different rooms and the
one person yawns and then they oh yeah
those mythbusters that was weird
that was the alex jones episode was it
yeah i don't remember they were in
different rooms
yeah mythbusters they put they like they
like they're i don't call
we'll call them phone booths they're
like booths and they had all the people
in them and then one person
yawned and then people started mirror
neurons i think i think that's what
happened i don't know it's been like
psychedelic
energy i'm telling you your brains are
electric you forget
you have electromagnetic fields don't
forget to follow at sourpatch lids as
well
l-i-d-s on which platform on twitter
just twitter that's all i have
i do and uh i guess you have a nice
instagram page too
shout out to lydia's instagram yeah yeah
what's your instagram yeah it's
ultraviolet with a four instead of an a
so that's why i don't share it okay cats
we will be back tomorrow at 8pm thank
you ladies and gentlemen for hanging out
and we will see you all
you